it is the Lesser known GOP debates
tonight so we're going to hang out and I
guess um make fun of the remaining
people who aren't going to be president
okay look we we're big fans of a
ramaswami but let's be real as much as
we we like the guy and as much as a lot
of us have routinely praised Ronda
sanz's leadership in Florida none of
these guys are going to be president but
I think it's still worth listening to
what they have to say and then probably
making fun of a lot of it or agreeing
with some of it you know credit where
credits do I don't know what Chris
Christie is still doing here but
whatever fine if he wants to be there
there is a bunch of news um that that
might come up Donald Trump basically
said he'll be dictator for one day just
one day and uh that was pretty funny Joe
Biden just canceled a whole lot more
student debt so we'll try to go quick
because the debate is starting now
before we get started head over to cast
brew.com to buy the best cup of coffee
you'll ever have cast Brew is our
company it's how we sponsor the show and
if you like coffee you'll like our
coffee because appalachin nights Raj
with robberto junor stand your grounds
those are our three Blends you got
medium you got light you got dark we got
ground whole bean coffee pods and a
whole bunch of other uh uh Blends we
even got Mr Bokus pumpkin spice
experience and our limited edition Reise
with Roberto Jr if you like the work we
do you can uh support us by buying cast
brew coffee but also go to Tim cast.com
click join us there's not going to be a
members only show tonight because we're
going to be doing a debate commentary
but we will read your super chats
periodically when we get an opportunity
and so uh get your super chats in but um
you'll you will get access as a member
to our Discord server we can hang out
with like-minded individuals and join
the party there's there's pre-shows
there's after shows happening in our
members only Discord so again smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show right now if you'll like
the work that we do joining us tonight
to talk about this and a whole lot more
is Tom sour hey what's going on guys hey
such a pleasure to be back here with you
guys total honor really enjoy it so I'm
a Navy Marine Corps Special Operations
veteran and and I run a company that
serves ascl Veterans for mental health
and addiction treatment that's what we
do so I was in town on the hill
advocating for uh all the guys and gals
who are really seeking help so but
obviously having a good time enjoying
this let's go we got Hannah CL yeah I'm
Hannah CL I'm a writer for sr.com
otherwise known as scanner I have my
crystals and I'm Ian Crossland what's
happening and I'm s.com and uh let's get
right to it let the debate begin and we
are live on news a and the CW oh the CW
is make or break time for the candidates
if primary starting just weeks away and
we have a lot to cover over the next two
Ron looks tall looking at his shoes he
looks taller it's will have 90 seconds
to oh look him he's wearing them he's
wearing them
again you see his boots you see his
boots you will all see the timing lights
that will indicate when time is up stop
talking oh he does not look good man is
critical over the next two hours so we
ask the audience to please keep your
applause to a minimum excellent all
right with that let's get started is
that Megan Kelly on Chris chy still here
four candidates
all and given the State of Affairs in
our political system right now large one
of you very well do it even many
Democrats now admit that President Biden
is a weak candidate just as many
Republicans acknowledge that former
president Donald Trump's multiple legal
TR
could
imperil a rumble his quest for a second
term all of which means one of you could
wind up the leader of the Free World
having said that maybe just maybe Mr
Trump is nearly 50 points ahead of
all 29 points ahead in Iowa where the
GOP caucuses are less than six weeks
away and so as Republicans get ready to
vote on whether any of you might be
preferable to Mr Trump we begin with the
question of electability
Governor Dan santis your campaign and
its Super PAC have spent the most money
had the most high net worth donors and
had a wave of momentum coming into this
race after your big re-election win in
Florida he looks very you were seen by
many as the candidate most likely to
consolidate the non-trump field he looks
really unhappy but here we are a month
out from the first real votes and you
haven't managed they tried that saw
right is beating you in New Hampshire
and South Carolina now and closing on
you in Iowa not to mention Trump who is
not only dominating in the early States
but is beating you in Florida by over 30
points jez is it fair to say as Senator
Tim Scott did when he dropped
out no but not now only Rosie so we have
a great idea in America that the vo
actually make these decisions not
pundits or poers sick of hearing
about in November 22 they said there was
going to be a big red wave it was going
to be Monumental and that crashed and
burned the one place it didn't Crash and
Burn was in the State of Florida they
weren't predicting that I would win the
way I did and I won the greatest
Republican victory in the history of the
State of Florida I'm looking forward to
to Iowa and New Hampshire the voters are
going to be able to speak and we're
going to earn this nomination and here's
what we need uh I am sick of Republicans
who are not willing to stand up and
fight back against what the left is
doing to this country you've got to be
willing to stand strong and you've got
to be willing to beat these people I'm
the only one running for president that
is beaten these people on issue after
issue uh we beat the teachers unions
when we did school choice we beat fouchy
on Co we beat George Soros when we
removed two of his radical District
Attorneys we beat the Democrats on
Election Integrity I have delivered
results that's what we need for this
country and you have other candidates
like
any time the left comes after anytime
the media comes after her I did a bill
in Florida to stop the gender mutilation
Min and it's wrong she opposes that
bill shouldn't get involved with it
you're not willing to stand up for the
kids if you're not willing to stand up
and say that it is wrong to mutilate
these kids uh then you're not going to
fight for the people he's in trouble now
CU he can never take off fight for you
and I will win for
you who dropped three overnight on TV
yeah Ambassador Haley you left
government service in 2018 with just
$100,000 in the bank 5 years later your
reported million thanks to Luc lucrative
corporate speeches and board memberships
like you had with Boeing weeks ago you
met with Wall Street heavyweights
including leaders from JP Morgan Goldman
Sachs and black rock several other
billionaire investors are reportedly
ready to endorse you or recently have
all of which comes with expectations
aren't you too tight with the banks and
the billionaires to win over the gop's
workingclass base which mostly wants to
break the system not elect someone
beholding if she said yes I might
actually consider you it's great to be
here you know first I'll tell you um
just to respond to Ron I he continues to
lie about my record I actually said the
Val of because it only talked about
going to dodge her own question by I
said it shouldn't be done at all talk
about it shouldn't be talked about
they're like oh she's worth $7 million
now it's like pretty weak actually if
you're like a governor
Ambassador only made7 million
that's I was a Tea Party candidate when
I became Governor it was popular opposed
every single corporate bailout we
possibly could we passed tort reform we
passed one of the toughest illegal
immigration laws in the country we
passed pro-life bills we moved in
unemployment from 11% to 3% we took on
the unions and we took on Obama when it
came to the unions the Syrian refugees
and everything in between
I actually am really impressed with
r standing in those he is really hard
but it's true I meanes they don't I
don't ask them what their Poli they ask
me what my policies are and I tell them
what it is sometimes they agree with me
sometimes they don't some don't like how
tough Trump is like a schoolyard bully
like ganging up on someone else with his
buddies behind him going like look at
that fat cow over there she's so fat
doesn't matter that's who I am and
that's why conservative Grassroots group
in the country Americans
for she gives exwife to
[Laughter]
me she gonna replace CHR Jill brand as
America's ex-wife it was about
prohibiting sex change operations on
minors they do puberty blockers these
are irreversible talk to Chloe Cole she
went through this now she's an adult
she's warning against it she may never
be able to have kids again out Nikki
haly opposed she said the law shouldn't
get involved in that which is Wild by
the way when
she pres of the United States and you
can't stand up Against Child Abuse how
are you going to be able to is narrow
that is the
truth answer on this that if you have to
be 18 to get a tattoo you should have to
be 18 to have anything done to change
the law should stay out of
it she said it was like up to the
parents and it's like no actually no
for that coming back to this issue Mr
mate your for months you campaigned as a
unifier then you stood up at the first
debate and attacked all of your
competitors as bought and paid for the
second debate you changed your tune
saying these are good people on this
stage admitting you can come across as a
bit of a know-it-all and rejecting the
practice of personal
insults by debate number three you
called Nikki haly corrupt accused Ronda
santis of wearing high heels
and keep a closer eye on her da he not
wrong can you see how you not in fact a
unifier and to question your
authenticity Megan I think there's a
time and place for everything we need
somebody in the White House who
absolutely is going to be a fighter when
it counts and I did say that there were
some good people on that stage in that
third debate Doug bergham was on that
stage at that time B Mania jokingly
Ronda s is a good person too I want to
go back though to Nikki Haley's comment
from earlier that she is somehow not
responding to the will of these owners
Nikki you were bankrupt when you left
the UN after you left the UN you became
a military contractor you actually
started joining service on the board of
Boeing whose back you scratched for a
very long time and then gave foreign
multinational speeches like Hillary
Clinton is and now you're a
multi-millionaire that math does not add
up it adds
up and when I said they were paid for I
meant the Republican establishment not
the Democratic establ now you have
who effectively George Soros Jr funding
lawsuits across this country against
Donald Trump to keep him off the ballot
funding left-wing causes we discovered
this week that he is one of Nikki
Haley's largest supporters Larry think
the K industrial complex the ESG
CEO silly but like you're governor and
Ambassador because it's after that
meeting later that day that she says
that every American needs to be doxed by
having their ID their government issued
ID tied to what they say on the internet
so I think that this is far more corrupt
than I even imagined when I entered
politics but I will say this it is going
to take a leader from the outside with
fresh legs from the Next Generation to
unite this country not the broken
politicians who are puppets of the
Puppet Master but the actual people in
this country Thomas Jefferson was3 when
the
I think it's going to take some best
days in life are still ahead to see a
country whose best days are ahead of
itself and I think I can reach that next
Generation better than anybody else
stage on this stage I'm the vake all day
all day easily he always can outperform
everybody verbally he answered perfectly
first of all we weren't bankrupt when I
left the UN we're people of service my
husband is in the military and I served
our country as un Ambassador and
Governor it may be bankrupt to him but
certainly wasn't bankrupt to us secondly
I did serve on the board of Boeing I did
a lot of work with Boeing when I was
governor they were a great partner to me
I served for 10 months and then when
they decided after covid that they
wanted to go for a corporate bailout
I've never supported corporate bailout
so I respectfully stepped back and got
off the board I love Boeing they build
good commercial airplanes they build
airplanes for our Air Force I am proud
of them they employ a lot of people in
South Carolina but that's why I left the
Boeing board there's nothing to what
he's saying and in terms of these donors
that are supporting me they're just
jealous they wish that they were
supporting them but I'm not going to
they just date me they're just jealous
they
got he wrot a book talking about ESG and
these woke corporations in Black Rock
the idea that I want to do that in
Florida they were managing our pens part
of our pension and then when they did
the ESG I took $2 billion away from
Black Rock we took action this ESG
again Nikki is said yes the camera went
they want to use economic power to
impose a leftwing agenda on this country
they want basically to change society
without having to go through the
Constitutional process we've kneecap it
in the State of Florida the next
president of the United States needs to
be able to go to that office on day one
in N ESG and the fact of the matter is
we know from her history Nikki will cave
to those big donors when it Count's 100%
right 100% right
[Applause]
quick well I did write that book Ron and
the irony is Nikki Haley was heaping
Praise on me when I wrot that but now I
worry I was warning about the woke
industrial complex in this country my
wife just texted me saying this looks
like Mystery Science theer 3000 you know
just like watching and comenting that's
actually far more dangerous than this is
really important for people to
understand we're marching towards
fascism under Biden Jack Smith has
subpoena every last retweet that someone
has issued from Donald Trump in the year
2020 the only person more fascist than
the Biden regime now is Nikki Haley who
thinks the government should identify
every one of those individuals with an
ID that is not Freedom that is fascism
and she should come nowhere near the
levers of power let alone the White
House I've got to get to Governor chrisy
heaved can you speak how you doing good
good to see it can you please
speak reement be here it would have been
great if she was like Chris can you go
themselves they're both exit I would be
happy to and I love all the attention
fell thank you for um you know I will
I'll say this what I said was that
social media companies need to show us
their algorithms I also said there are
millions of bots on social media right
now they're foreign they're Chinese
they're Iranian I will always fight for
freedom of speech for Americans we do
not need freedom of speech for Russians
and Iranians and Hamas we need social
media companies to go and fight back on
all of these that are Happ that's what I
said as a mom as a mom do I think social
media would be more civil if we wouldn't
had people's names next to that yes I do
think that because I think we've got too
much cyber bullying I think we've got
child pornography and all of those
things but having said that I never said
government should go and require
anyone's name false he said I want your
name the United States age high five now
said
can the
tap I actually really loveon
te real
serious so because it' be a massive
expansion of government we have anous
speech the say it I'm saying going to
bring up a and sit down they're never
going to get to Pub something that's and
especially can we make Nikki Haley as
America
married
own give you 15 seconds and then there
is the governor former
Governor because Ron is so hypocritical
because he actually went and tried to
push a law that would stop Anonymous um
people from talking to the press and
went so far to say bloggers should have
to register with the state if they're
going to talk about right about elected
officials it was in the M check your
newspap
gross trample on your constitutional
this is more dangerous than the democ I
love defending R awesome just I'm
usually not somebody who gets missed but
okay let's go that's not true 2% he's
making a comment about his
weight 201 and 2020 you gave him an a
for his first term since then however
you've turned on him calling him a li a
loser a man and
Cann
win man oh you're big his approval
rating with Republicans is currently at
81% yours is at 25 your best state is
New Hampshire and even there 2third of
GOP voters say they would be angry and
disappointed if you
won you have not stopped Mr Trump that
Wass May wonder how you could
Poss of a party that does not appear to
like you very much does not appear to
like you Megan um it's often very
difficult to be the only person on the
stage who's telling the truth and the
only person who is taking on what needs
to be taken on I look at my watch now
we're 17 minutes into this debate I
haven't spoken before except for your
little speech in the beginning we've had
these three acting as if the race is
between the four of
us the fifth guy who doesn't have the
guts to show up and
stand he's the one who as you just put
it is way ahead in the polls why do he
I've got these three guys who are all
seemingly to compete um with you know
Voldemort heo shall not be named they
don't want to talk about it he just gave
him power fact is that when you go and
you say the truth about somebody who is
a dictator a
buly who has taken shots at everybody
whether they've given a great
service is he seriously saying I'm going
to attack the most popular Republican
right now and that's going to me make me
win who I endorsed in 201 how is he
going to win
if Trump pulling like anding maybe those
future aspirations are now or maybe
they're years from but the fact of the
matter is the truth needs to be told and
for us to go 17 minutes without
discussing the guy who has all those
Gody numbers you talked about is
ridiculous from Trump's way I'm in this
race because the truth needs to be
spoken he is unfit this is a guy who
just said this past week want imagine
being in high school and there's like
kid being like is dumb foring him he is
unfit to be president and there is no
biger call the truth which is that Trump
is ultim Donal in this debate app I just
don't think his criticism actually
helped
himing but I'd like to first get to some
questions there do we know somebody
where they C
war and have
surrounded Americans have been hel
someone down there can you tell them to
stop not normal people there American
troops and warships in the Middle East
are under attack how far would you go as
president to secure the release of those
eight American hostages and would it
include sending American forces into
combat yes we have to look out for our
people when they are hostages
commanderin-chief you have to do
whatever you can to get them done but
the overall issue with this is this
Administration is trying to hobble
Israel from being being able to defend
itself they have a right to eliminate
Hamas and win a total and complete
Victory so that they never have to deal
with this again Hamas wants nothing less
than a second Holocaust they would wipe
off every single Jew off the map they
would destroy the state of
Israel Jo Biden will say they support
Israel and then they do nothing try to
kneecap them every step of the way you
should not try to direct try to an
answer it comes so that they can bring
Hamas to heal look I
back in the day I'm the only one running
for president that served milary I
understand that part of the world uh
it's not the best part of the world uh
we do have troops there that Biden is
leaving basically is sitting ducks and
you have the Iranians that are attacking
these troops and he's responding with
basically pin Pricks if you harm an
American Service member you're going to
have hell to pay when I'm President we
are not going to let our troops be
sitting ducks we also need to look at
what's the underlying problem here Iran
Biden is doing nothing to bring Iran to
account you got to turn the screws on
them don't let them have any oil
Revenue they send to Hamas they send and
they F Jihad throughout the Middle East
so Biden has empowered Iran just like
he's empowered other adversaries we
stand with Israel they're our best ally
in the Middle East we have a unique
relationship with them uh and you will
see a strong relationship when I'm the
president of the United
States
Elizabeth th this is the problem with
the first three debates Ron gets asked a
question and he doesn't answer it your
question was very specific you said
would you send American troops as
commanderin-chief
and he went on to
this about his knowledge of the military
and what we need to do and didn't answer
your question foris pres unit States
you're not going to have a choice
whether to answer that question or not
your generals your secretary of defense
your secretary of State your National
Security adviser are going to present
plans to you they're going to look at
you and say do we go or don't we Mr
President and you can't give a 90 second
speech about your military services what
would you send American troops into res
absolutely absolutely if they had a plan
which showed me that we could get them
out safely you're damn right I'd send
the americ
take really bad idea not go well good
ide here wait you have said it was
irresponsible for Ambassador Haley to
call hamas's terrorist Rampage an attack
on America and for her to quote rabidly
shout finish them end quote rabidly the
Hamas terror attack left dozens of
Americans dead and was the deadliest
attack on Jews since the Holocaust why
wouldn't it be a good thing to finish
Hamas finish them was purposefully vague
in a discussion that included Iran which
is what I objected to and I think it's
as US president you have to be
responsible what happened to Israel was
dead wrong what Hamas did was medieval
it was subhuman it was immoral and we
have to call that out for what it is on
OCT hand gesture but to say that that
was an attack on America fails a basic
test I mean Nick if you can't tell the
difference between where Israel is and
the US is on a map I can have my
three-year-old son show you the
difference that is irresponsible because
it has major consequences because that
does leave for because she's passinger
so I believe I have the strongest
pro-israel position actually on the
stage even though it's a little bit
different than the standard GOP talking
points and it is this the founding
vision of Israel David benan the George
Washington Figure of Israel what did he
believe he believed that we don't want
as Israel to depend on the fleeting
sympathies of the West and have our
hands tied I think Israel has an
absolute right to defend itself to the
fullest without the US the UN or the EU
or anybody else second guessing their
decisions as the Biden Administration
guess what is now starting to do I think
that's a more deeply pro-israel position
than anybody else and it keeps the
actual lines of accountability clear
because it is a pro-american position
and as leader of the United States of
America just as as a father of two sons
my sole moral duty is to my family as
your next president my sole moral duty
is to you the people of this country
that's how I'm going to lead so I'll
tell BB you smoke the terrorists on your
Southern border you go ahead and we're
rooting for you we're going to smoke the
terrorists on our own Southern border
that's how I'm going to leave this
country but Americans were killed in
that attack Americans were killed in
that attack and so if you if you looked
at this terrorist attack and the number
of Americans this would be one of the
top 10 terrorist attacks in American
history so our own people were killed in
that attack and I think it's absolutely
appropriate to point that out and to say
that we're in this together uh and we
are going to work with Israel so that
these people are brought to Justice I
agree with that Ambassador Haley I'm
coming to you I Iran is on the threshold
of becoming a nuclear State The Wall
Street Journal reported that Iranian
military leaders gave the green light
for hamas's Attack on Israel you said in
last month's debate that by contrast to
the Biden administration's approach to
Iran you would quote punch them once and
punch them hard were you saying that
it's time to bomb Iran no I was not
saying it's time to bomb Iran but I will
tell you I dealt with Iran every day
when I was at the United Nations and
they only respond to strength what they
don't respond to is when you weaken the
sanctions like they did on Iran that
allowed China to send them billions to
fill their proxies what they don't
respond to is when you give billion for
five hostages that only makes them want
more hostages what they don't respond to
is when they do 140 strikes on our men
and women in Syria and Iraq and we do
nothing but just some small shots back
you've got to punch them you've got to
punch them hard and let them know that
that's the only way they're going to
respond so the way you do that is you go
after their infrastructure in Syria and
Iraq where they're hitting our soldiers
that's what you do and then that's when
they'll back off the problem is you have
to see that all of these are related if
you look at the fact Russia was losing
that IR to 65 he was getting drones and
missiles drones from Iran missiles from
North Korea and so what happened when he
hit rock bottom all of a sudden his
other friend Iran
Hamas goes and invades Israel and
butchers those people on Putin's
birthday there is no one happier right
now I got I got okay here we go we got a
Super Chat Dustin Trussell said if Chris
Christie devoured Nikki Haley live on
stage I would vote for that' be a good
cartoon Sheamus you listening at this
point I have to agree because she's just
talking so much garbage a reason again
that Taiwanese want to help ukrainians
because they know if Ukraine wins China
won't invade Taiwan there's a reason the
ukrainians want to help Israelis because
they know that if Iran wins Russia wins
these are all connected but what wins
all of that is a strong America not we
America she's basically like we have to
have War because everybody is bad all
the time experience is not the same as
foreign policy wisdom I want everybody
at home know that I was the first person
to say we need a reasonable peace deal
in Ukraine now a lot of the neocons are
quietly coming along to that position
with the exceptions of Nikki Haley and
Joe Biden who still support this what I
believe is pointless war in Ukraine and
I think those with foreign policy
experience one thing that Joe Biden and
Nikki Haley have in common is that
neither of them could even state for you
three provinces in eastern Ukraine that
they want to send that to actually fight
for look at that this is what I want
people to understand these people have I
mean she has no idea what the
hell got
got equ to go fight
you that
some the makes 8 million bucks after has
real foreign policy experience it takes
an outsider to see this through look at
the blank expression
she literally eating
her
right hold is moderating thank you you
know his reasonable peace deal in
Ukraine he made it clear give them all
the land they've already stolen
promise Putin you'll never put Ukraine
in Russia and then trust Putin not to
have a relationship with China let me
tell you something that's no
reasonable yes it's exactly what you
said you do this at every
debate don't interrupt I didn't inter
you okay you
say you do this debate you go out on the
stump and you say something all of us
see it on video we confront you on on
the debate stage you say you didn't say
it and then you back away and I want to
say I'm not done yet that's
actually get I think Chris misspoke when
he said put Ukraine in Russia the fourth
debate that in the first 20 minutes as
the most obnoxious blow hard in America
so shut up for a little while I'm I'm
going to respond to
that e want say something else y we're
now 25 minutes into this debate
and he has insulted Nikki Haley's basic
intelligence not her positions her basic
intelligence she doesn't know regions
she wouldn't be able to find something
on
mapy information if you want to disagree
on issues and Nikki and I disagree on
some issues but I'll tell you this I've
known her for 12 years which is longer
than he's even started to vote in a
Republican
primary that's not a Argent we disagree
and we disagree
should we don't disagree on this is a
smart accomplish woman you should stop
insulting so I'm going to take this I'm
going to take several times
over white for Nikki just learn
something Christ
no we learned three things right there
first of all Chris Christie also doesn't
know what provinces in eastern Ukraine
he actually want us to fight
for foreign policy experience Ron is
laughing at that closing a bridge from
New Jersey to New York so do everybody a
favor just walk yourself off that stage
enjoy a nice meal and get the hell out
of this
race I think you're going to actually
send your sons and daughters to go die
in somebody else's you excuse me Chris
I'm speaking and I'm not done yet you
and we're going to be done so listen up
to this is if these people want to send
your sons and daughters to go die in
Ukraine they've been arguing for it for
a year $200 billion of our taxpayer
money over neither of them could even
name for you the provinces that they
actually want to protect and this is the
people who have been touting their soal
foreign policy experience it is
intellectual fraud these people are
lying to you the same people who told
you about weapons and mass destruction
in Iraq to justify that Invasion didn't
know the first thing about it yet they
sent thousands of our sons and daughters
stop he's already
dead trillion of our national debt due
to these toxic
NEP on a still a fascist
neoc all over again this Mr ramasami 15
gas in the stage dude wow name the
provinces
neither not Crimea it's not crime that's
not the one they're talking about Flo is
CHR all right let me just say this you
know this is the kind thing where he
talks about experience you know I was
the US attorney in New Jersey when the
terrorist attacks were launched against
the United States in 2001 I brought the
two first two cases in this country
against terrorists who tried to attack
us again got point I know about the
threat of terrorism bullying remember
911 argument doesn't work when you have
a large voter based younger voters who
were
not were little children or not even
alive I was M at Harvard Marine active
duty guy but like I was fact that back
then was a Democrat but even but you
remember fact
is all he knows there are actual voters
right
now know how to do is insult good people
who have committed their lives to public
service and not say anything that moves
the ball down the field for the United
States all right thank you Governor
Chris I hate the term Public Service
sorry if if you're elected official
you're
not because has been rushed for a long
time that's not what's in contention
right now right right right and so V I
think he absolutely nailed them with
that question uh which which provinces
do you actually want to defend well
they're called oasts administrative
regions and they're basically just named
after their cities but everyone knows DK
and Lans those are the the principal in
the in in the donbass region and then I
guess the argument would be KV and Kiev
which is where uh Russian forces and and
attacked from through Belarus Crimea
they want to liberate not defend but I
don't want to be too pedantic nck Haley
I don't know how she got those answers
someone rushed to you know did she like
check her phone look down and be like
quick me I think the face when he she
she is waiting for the moderators to be
like and now you speak and that's not
the game of V is playing that's not the
game to a certain extent Dan santis is
playing like he said it she didn't even
realize the camera is on her so she's
staring blankly because she's listening
to someone who's standing over there
maybe she does know the region maybe she
doesn't but it was perfectly teed up by
ramaswami she was not quick enough to
respond that's really what it was I
think the fact that she said Crimea show
she doesn't know what she's talking
about she doesn't and it took her like
five minutes to get to it right she
could have said it immediately instead
she was flustered by being Crimea has
been for for a decade under the control
of Russia and and and and sasti the
Russians have already been there well
before that with their Naval Base so
he's so maybe you can argue she didn't
understand what ex he meant and she was
interpreting as but I'm I'm not playing
that game he immediately called her out
and if it were me I'd be like it it look
first of all I don't actually care that
much about Ukraine my my my whole
position is more align with v of we
should not be uh sending troops over
there and and fortifying this but
immediately I was like wait I'm like
denk and Lans like that's the news I I
can name those two right now now and
then as you be president too Tim yeah
the one thing I'm not sure of is I know
those are the names of of the regions
but but I I fact checked they're
basically the names of the Cities so KV
KV those are also the names of the Bel
reading M
Etc well the funny thing is if you think
about it right so it's like you know we
pull out of Afghanistan in the most
horrible way surrender I you know my
buddy who came with me here who's you
know downstairs right now like he was up
like got no sleep for weeks uh trying to
get guys out right a lot of guys did
right trying to get guys out of there it
was a total disaster and then 6 months
later you know all the you know the
military industrial complex right they
needed uh new business you know so it's
like Business Development like what do
you know right 6 months later we got a
new war more money all that you know I
like I'm not trying to sound too
conspiratorial but you know looks that
way yeah when they split up the Soviet
Union and they gave all that land to you
the Ukraine those oligarchs must have
known it was going to cause contention
with Russia down the line not having
access to the Black Sea we don't call it
the Ukraine we call it Ukraine it is
Borderland yeah you're absolutely true
I'm not I'm I'm no like Eastern European
Russian expert like but right it's like
it's like all everyone has to say keev
now instead of Kev you know like come on
we've spelled zin's name like three
different ways is crazy how many wise
fewer wise maybe more wise seven wise I
think it is worth noting that ultimately
Christie was right that it's about Trump
more than anything else uh and it is
interesting to watch the fighting like
it's not I think V is performing well
they' you know there have been
interesting moments but ultimately it
the question remains how will anyone
stand up if they were to debate Trump
they won't I it shows the two legitimate
candidates is DeSantis and ramaswami and
the other two are like warhawks that are
just kind of on the trail big money yeah
100% that's like that's absolutely it
and honestly like you I was saying
earlier is like on that stage on that
stage like fex the guy he's the guy
absolutely for for like normal F I think
he has the Charisma I mean I think there
are questions about his policies in some
respects but I think he always has been
the most charismatic person in in all of
these debate performances again he does
have the occasional thing you know he
said something like I have a longer
future than Donald Trump he has he has
sparred with Donald Trump very
indirectly and again I wonder what that
would look like if they were up against
each other it's more anecdotal but he's
he's humble in the sense that he was
willing to come in and and do this
interview when Tim was out of town even
though so I interview and Hannah Clair
interviewed him Sheamus cogin and hold
on it's worse than that we had we we we
had a miscommunication here about who
was contacting his team to let him know
that I was at the at a doctor's
appointment not going to be in town and
so they found out really late and V was
super cool like no no don't worry about
it I get it man these things happen
indication to me he will listen to his
advisers like that's a huge important
thing for for leader absolutely but also
the fact that like he'll go talk
anywhere he'll He he'll go like I mean
obvious this is a huge show huge show
but it's like he'll he goes on all the
podcasts it's great on the southern does
not poll show immigration and the crisis
are among the most pressing issues for
Republican voters right now both the
issue of migrants Crossing illegally
into our country and the separate issue
of fenel being smuggled in mostly
through legal ports of Entry all year
news nation has been at the border
documenting the crisis in 2023 alone
border patrol encountered a record new
na does a pretty good J migrant all four
of you have talked tough question now is
how realistic is the talk so Governor
DeSantis I'd like to start with you you
have pledged to send the military to the
southern border on day one of your
Administration with Ord to shoot stone
cold dead anyone illegally entering with
a backpack that you believe contains
fenel critics have called this a shoot
first ask questions later policy that
would amount to extra judicial killing
you are a former military lawyer why do
you think this idea of yours would be
legal the drug cartels are invading our
country and they are killing our
citizens by the tens of thousands every
year uh we had a situation in Florida
there was an 18-month old baby that was
crawling on the floor of an a Airbnb
rental there was fenel residue on the
carpet and the baby died is this
acceptable in this country I know the
Elites in DC they don't care they don't
care that fentanyl is ravaging your
community they don't care that illegal
aliens are are ravaging our community
and overwhelming our community the
commanderin-chief not only has a right
you have a responsibility to fight back
against these people and does that mean
shooting first it means you're going to
you're going to categorize them as
foreign terrorist organizations uh and
we will identify just like we would
anywhere when I was in Iraq the Iraq the
the al-Qaeda wasn't wearing a uniform
you'd see anyone walking down the street
they all had man dresses on you didn't
know if someone had a a bomb an IED
attached or not and so you had to make a
judgment based on intelligence based on
positive identification but we're going
to be able to get the Intelligence on
these cartel people and here's the thing
if we had a wall across the southern
border which I support this would not
have happened we need to build a wall
across the southern border I'll get it
done and I'll make for Mexico is
supposed to pay for it remember here's
how you do that I'm going to have fees
on remittances from foreign workers when
they send the money back to foreign
countries we're going to tax it and
we're going to build a wall with that so
yes you should have had that but we
don't have it I'm going to build it but
we have to lean in on this problem I am
not going to sit there and allow mothers
to lose more kids because of fentanyl
overdose I am not going to sit there and
let sex trafficking go unabated or human
trafficking go unabated there's going to
be a new sheriff in town and these drug
cartels better nothing disagreeable
there Ambassador Haley you have pledged
to catch and
deorta off the system which is it so
first of all what I said is all of the
seven or eight million illegals that
have come under Biden's watch absolutely
have to go back we have to stop the
incentive of what's bringing them over
here in the first place Biden just gave
temporary protective status to 500,000
Venezuelans that's a half a million
social security cards that's a half a
million driver's licenses and I know
from my time at the United Nations the
first thing they do is pick up the phone
and said we came over come on over and
that's what sends more you have to go
and Deport these people so they know it
can't happen again for those that have
been here longer than that we've got to
start seeing who is how long have they
been here have they been vetted paid
taxes have they been working and figure
out who else is out there but what I
know is my parents came here leally they
put in the time they put in the price
they are offended by those that are
coming illegally we can't let them skip
the line but when you talk about Fel
like you did before let's look at
something else yes I think we should
send Special Operations over and take
out the cartels I think we should do a a
remain a Mexico policy so they never
step foot in US soil in the first place
but look at where fentanyl came from
let's go to the heart of the matter it
came from China that's why we need to
end all normal trade relations with
China until they stop murdering
Americans with fentanyl I promise you
they need our economy they will
immediately stop that but this is where
Trump went wrong Trump was good on trade
but that's all he was with China because
here he allowed fentanyl to continue to
come over he continued to allow them to
take he would give them technology that
would build up their military and hurt
us he allowed the Chinese infiltration
for them to buy up Farmland to put money
in our universities and to continue to
do things that were harmful for America
we now have a spy Base in Cuba and
police stations and Trump didn't do
anything about China though I mean
listen this is Rich because when she was
governor of South Carolina she was the
number one ranked governor of bringing
the CCP into her State she wrote a love
letter to the Chinese Ambassador saying
how great a friend China is you can look
at it we put it on our website rondes
sanus.com there's also a video of her as
Governor standing in front of a Chinese
flag with a Chinese business saying that
she now works for them talking about
this Chinese company so she's been very
weak on China now here's the problem the
rhetoric is different but the one one
her donors these Wall Street liberal
donors they make money in China they are
not going to let her be
China and she will cave to the donor she
will not stand up for
you not I think Ron's actually doing
really well is first of all he's mad
because those Wall Street donors used to
support him and now they support me the
second thing
is
Chinese that he just did a rally there
last year they have given you 40,000
Camp between them and their
employees to the communist jeno solar is
another one they went and expanded you
gave 2 million in subsidies I banned
China from buying land in the State of
Florida department I ejected The
confucious Institute Nikki Haley brought
confucious institutes to the
universities in South Carolina I ejected
them so I have a record of standing up
and do what's right and and here's the
thing she's she's trying to say things
like that even the liberal media groups
that usually if I say the sky is blue
they'll fact check me and say that's
wrong they look at the charges they said
it was totally FAL that they could not
find one instance of me recruiting a
Chinese business coming to Florida you
know why because we never recruited any
Chinese
businesses thank you thank you Mr
ramaswami over the past year senel has
killed more than 75,000 Americans 1,000
of them right here in Alabama you have
vowed to use the military to quote
annihilate drug Labs inside Mexico
something the president of Mexico said
would be a hostile act but fenel can
easily be made anywhere and Labs that
are shut down can easily and quickly be
replaced are your tough enforcement
policies offering false hope to a
country racked by addiction to the
contrary I don't think it's going to
have to come to that if we deal with the
actual demand side problem that we also
have in this country I mean the easy
part is talking about how we're going to
use our military to secure the Border I
will and I believe that everybody else
wants to do the same thing but the
harder part is dealing with the crisis
of purpose and meaning the mental health
epidemic ring across this country like
wildfire and there's a reason why after
the opioid crisis you see Fentanyl and
even after we get fentanyl and we are
going to be sure to make sure we do it
this one is worse for many reasons
they're illegally lacing it into
Pharmaceuticals so it's more dangerous
but we're deluding ourselves the real
false promise here is thinking that
we're going to have dealt with that
under underlying mental health epidemic
in this country by just dealing with the
demand side of it but I want to get back
to this issue of the root cause CU a lot
of these are coming from labs and w uhan
China of all places drug materials that
are going to the Mexican drug cartels
that they're pumping across that
southern border like a modern Opium War
I think it is going to take a US
president that's going to have a very
different conversation with xiin ping
than what Joe Biden just had in
California I will tell sh you will not
only not buy land in this country or
donate universities in this country us
businesses won't expand into the Chinese
market until they're playing by the same
set of rules and the same country that's
putting fentanyl into to Illegal
Pharmaceuticals in Mexico it's no
coincidence is the exact same country
that also Unleashed hell on the world
with the covid-19 pandemic we also have
to hold them accountable with every
Financial lever that we have available
that is what it actually means to stand
with a spine and you mark my words if
we're willing to stand with the spine
China will absolutely have to fold
because they're in a tougher spot than
we are and then we're back to plane by
the same set of rules than you Mr Swami
thank you let's talk about the economy
Ambassador
Haley has always been part of the
American dream but it'sing Out Of Reach
for younger Americans this year mortgage
rates reach 30-year highs home prices
have risen
$190,000 over the past decade is this
the free market at work or should the
federal government do something to home
more first of all you're exactly right
my daughter just got married and I saw
how hard it was for her and her husband
to buy buy a home right now the average
homeowner in America is 49 years old
you've got young people everywhere that
used to be the American dream and now
it's Out Of Reach but you look at what
happened you first of all look at what
the FED did the FED did a terrible job
when they allowed all of that money to
go through you saw the treasury bond
rates go up that affected mortgage rates
that affected automobile rates that
affected insurance rates and so now
we've have a high interest rate you've
got a supply issue ask any Builder the
supply issues have continued to build be
there that's caused the rate to go up
and then you've got insurances that have
gone up and so what you have is a lot of
younger people who one can't afford a
home but two the banks aren't lending
them any money they've made the
regulation so hard that they don't want
to give loans on mortgages anymore so
what we have to do is we have to open it
up we have to one grow our economy so
that people have more money in their
pockets we've got to look at the supply
chain and make sure that we are
funneling that so that Builders don't
have to sit there and go overseas to
find things and then we need to make
sure that we really stop paying down
this debt make sure that we stop the
borrowing stop the spending I'll veto
any spending bill that doesn't take us
back to pre-co levels because our kids
are not going to forgive us for all the
spending that happened and as much as
everybody wants to talk about how Donald
Trump had a good economy $9 trillion in
debt he did just in four years and we're
all paying the price of that including
those mortgage yeah but a lot of that
was extraordinary circumstan lot of
spending govern STIs the latest
news poll found that inflation tops the
worries of American voters 61% say
they're very concerned and the working
class is hard just not
here glut of federal spending moderating
the Biden Administration has added $6
trillion to the national debt so far but
president Trump wasn't exactly a penny
pincher why not Administration added 7.8
trillion do Republicans including
president Trump share the blame for
inflation and what concrete steps would
a president santis uh take to help
Americans make ends meet but it's not sh
Printing and spending of money was both
parties in Washington DC that's just the
fact these Republicans in Washington
have spent it's driven your prices
higher and it's driven your interest
rates to the point where you can't
afford I met a young fell in Iowa he had
graduated college a couple years ago and
he's like Governor I don't have a chance
I'm gainfully employed he's like I have
no chance to afford a home and start a
family that is taking the American dream
away from people so we're going to get
the inflation down we're going to get
the interest rates down we are going to
reduce spending and I will be willing to
veto and I vetoed a lot as governor of
Florida and we'll do that we're also
going to open up all of our domestic
energy for production lower your gas
prices lower the price of fuel that's
going to help the economy it also help
jobs and we'll do it but you know
another thing that's burdening young
people are these student loans
now I don't support having a truck
driver having to pay a student loan for
someone that got a degree in gender
studies that is wrong we should not have
taxpayers do that what I'm going to do
though is I'm going to get to the root
cause of the problem these student loans
are going to be backed by the
universities because they need to have
an incentive to produce
painful they should not be indulging in
ideological studies they should be
focusing on things that work and we're
going to take some of this money and
we're going to move it to actual
vocational training in Florida we
doubled apprenticeships we have more
truck drivers these are in demand skills
don't let anybody tell you that the only
way you can be successful is through a
four-year brick and Ivy degree that's
one way you can be it's not the only way
and we're going to fix that problem in
the United States of
[Applause]
America cryptocurrency like Bitcoin as
an opt out from our quote broken
Financial architecture and you oppose
efforts to regulate it wait for
cryto beut back for
terrorists you say your
C ensure economic freedom for Americans
end quote won't it also ensure economic
freedom frauders criminals and
terrorists frers criminals and
terrorists have been defrauding people
for a long time our regulations need to
catch up with the current moment the
fact that SBF was able to do what he at
FTX shows that whatever they have as the
current framework isn't working and I
think it is nothing short of
embarrassing that Gary Gensler the
current leader of the SEC in front of
Congress could not even say whether
ethereum counted as a regulated security
or not so I think that this is just
another example of the administrative
State gone too far here's the Dirty
Little Secret in American politics today
the people who we elect to run the
government are not the ones who are even
actually
what what are they not doing tell me
they're writing regulations that
Congress never gave them the authority
to write and the good news is a US
president can absolutely fix that that
takes a US president with a spine so
what I've said is in my Administration
by the end of year one we will have a
75% reduction in the number of federal
bureaucrats we will shut down government
agencies that should not exist we will
resend any regulation that fails the
test of West Virginia versus EPA which
is the most important Supreme Court case
of our lifetime that said if Congress
didn't delegate that to an
administrative agency then it's
unconstitutional these are seismic CH
know much about big changes that the
next president can deliver without
asking Congress for permission or for
forgiveness and I want people to
understand that distinction because
people have been sold myths by
politicians for a long time saying I'm
going to work with Congress to do this
or that much of what you've heard on the
stage from the other politicians fit
that descript they need Congress the
things that I'm promising you this is
what the leader of the executive branch
gets to do under article two of the
Constitution sir cut down the
bureaucracy cederal
govern one of the dangers that we're
going to face Biden once is a central
bank digital currency they want to get
rid of cash crypto they want to force
you to do that they'll take away your
privacy they will absolutely Reg your
purchases on day one as President we
take the idea of Central Bank digital
currency and we throw it in the trash
can it'll be dead on a I don't know if
anybody
ising how much have a whole second hour
to get to it's exciting and when we come
back we got a big subject yeah Ron Ron's
best debate so far to be honest he he's
a little nerdy he's a little nerdy um
and what I mean by that is lot good
facts yeah but not being presented
really well like I'm I'm talking like
high school level like he's not it's the
Charisma thing but I think he's doing
pretty well and uh V of course is always
uh uh doing really well you right that
he was a little too nerdy when he
started talking about ethereum uh and
that Gary Gensler couldn't identify if
it was a security or not basically means
is it is it going to be used as cash or
is it going to be used as a commodity
the word commodi is a little nerdy sure
for your
average we'll grab some super chats
during the commercials we got um MF
Damien says Ron makes some decent points
but sounds too rehearsed and inauthentic
when he speaks King VI all day yeah con
yeah that that like I feel like Ron's
actually doing really well yeah but he's
got the head Bob going on he needs to
smile once in a while I like a real
smile not not the whole like the Gavin
knew some smiling too weird I don't know
yeah he got called out because his
Smiles are inauthentic I won't let you
down yeah oh he looks sad when he and
also you you made a great point there
when you're talking about like the the
Gavin new bring that up like look you
when everyone says oh Gavin new like I
think Terry was here last night to
saying like oh I'm not that worried
about gav like I'm worried as hell about
Gavin newm this is this is a good one
right here from Nick Williams please Viv
missed an opportunity to highlight that
Haley isn't stupid she just doesn't care
about Ukraine the only thing Nikki is
worried about is locked and Ron stock
price yeah he didn't insult her
intelligence like Chris Christie said he
he pointed out that she didn't have the
information she was ignorant tomorrow
the headline is going to be Chris
Christie defends Nikki Haley from vake
who becomes too aggressive on stage
attacks women right and so in some ways
like the fact that he left ambiguous and
didn't correct it at all I mean he was
on a rooll he had good energy in that
moment so there's a reason to but it it
will give Chris Christie this moment and
it also makes Nikki Haley look like a
submissive woman which will turn
feminists off from her if there's any
you know VI staff members listening I
hope they hear this technically I hope
they don't but just you got to say Nikki
Hillary over here I'm sorry I mean Hy no
he did have that Hillary Clinton call
her n Nikki Hillary excuse me yeah like
and like fake you know texting now n
Hillary no but when he compared her to
Hillary Clinton like that's a very
serious indictment right women in
politics either side being compared to
Hillary Clinton is not a good thing
right cuz if you're a Democrat she
failed repeatedly and if you're a
republican it's Hillary Clinton yeah but
look look Hillary Clinton could be
running on the give you a million
dollars party and people would still
hate her yeah like it doesn't it doesn't
matter if if you're Republican or
Democrat policy-wise she is an awful
human that people despise America's
ex-wife when um yeah yeah actually yeah
that's when Nikki Haley came out and
said that she wanted to track people
that use social media and get their
identification make everyone that I
think indicates low intelligence like
that I can argue is a low intelligence
claim because she hasn't thought ahead
what kind of corruption
authoritarian authoritarianism let me
let me grab this one from Net One Gamer
he says I was born in November 2002 and
people my age were signing up to fight
in this war that has been around longer
than myself we're not doing that again
politicians can suck it thank you I I 21
years old okay you're 21 you've been you
so you you voted in several election
Cycles already and you were born after
but let's even talk about someone born
in 1997 okay you're four or five years
old you don't remember any of this so
when when Chris Christie's like I was
the the Attorney General during 911 it's
like yo that doesn't mean anything it it
might mean something to people who are
in their like mid-30s and up everybody
else they're like I don't I don't care I
think I was in kindergarten and I grew
up in Connecticut right so I had friends
whose parents commuted into New York
like I remember not going to school that
day The Towers fell but like all of it
is stuff that I grew up hearing but it's
not it was I had have teenagers right
who are like coming up military age it's
like you know and like for example right
like my little brother my little brother
is he's still active duty he's still out
there I got a lot of friends I got a
friend here's active duty and I got a I
know a lot of folks who are like younger
than me like and it's like I don't
really want you to the fall of the
Berlin Wall that's how I that's how 89 I
was three I was I was 3 years old uh
actually actually was yeah I was about
to turn four and I only have vague
memories of references to it right I'm
three I don't remember anything at all
other than it's not relevant people
mentioning it as I was a kid that it
happened takeh can I say something as
well when I what what V said he talks
about like cutting like 75% of like the
federal government is look it's
something that like a lot of people
especially people who you know live in
the Beltway other there it's like
Bonkers like oh my God you can't do it
right it's terrible it's crazy here we
go but I got to say it will be painful
itous it Happ
we'll I'm the frun in this Donal they
got to talk about
GDP as you
know we like to ask you a couple
questions about him now I think she's
wearing a greator I just have to say
looks great former president Trump
recently promised if he's reelected to
bring back and expand his program
restricting immigration from Muslim
countries did Trump actually say Muslim
countries October 16 Okay let's listen
let's listen how longer will we allow
dangerous lunatics haters bigots and
Maniacs to get residency in our country
we're not going to let them stay here if
you empathize with radical Islamic
terrorists and extremists you're
disqualified you're just disqualified
seems reasonable he didn't say mus
support president Trump's plan for
ideological screening oh come on I don't
think that you have a straight up Muslim
ban as much as you look at the countries
that have terrorist activity that want
oh come on to email Megan Kelly and be
like what was that
we look at it countries areat to us you
look at what came across the southern B
what worries me the most are those that
came from Iran from Yemen from Lebanon
those areas where they say death to
America that's where you want to
be
Rel sure Trump should ban terrorists if
someone is coming to this country and we
find out that they support terrorists
and radical ideologies you're
disqualified not a big ask it's not
crazy and and the the false framing by
Megan Kelly n n Haley is reprehensible
weing about it and the biggest threat we
have right now is communist China but
you have to also look at what Iran and
Russia are doing as well and we need to
be paying attention to that that's why
we have to focus on things like cyber on
space on artificial intelligence and not
just the regular things that we've
always focused on it's not just it's not
just terrorism though that's important
but look what's happened in Europe you
have more anti-Semitism in Germany than
at any time since a Hitler why because
they imported Mass numbers of people who
reject their culture Europe is
committing suicide with the mass
migration and it's illegal and legal uh
Nikki Haley said the other day there
should be no limits on on legal
immigration and that corporate CEO
should set the policy on that there
needs to be limits on immigration and we
should not be importing people from
cultures that are hostile so for example
I said with the Gaza you had some of the
the the squad wanted to import 300,000
people from the Gaza Strip I said no
we're not taking anyone from Gaza
because of the anti-Semitism and because
they reject American culture so we've
got to get smart about this we cannot
let the United States be like
Europe if I may just hit this point
because it relates to what they just
said there are things that the
government can do right now that
nobody's talking about professional
politicians in this race I don't think
he's got any I think he's got like one
or two questions for an hour here's the
answer there's 287g in the law that is a
provision that already allows ice agents
to deputize or allow local law
enforcement to enforce those ice Wars
and it shocks me that nobody in the
Republican part is talking about it
because there are 1 million then
officials law enforcement officials in
this country and against that backdrop
we absolutely have the ability to deport
anybody who's in this country illegally
talking allow that actually did that as
governor of South Carolina
govern night in Iowa he would be a
dictator if he wins the second term in
office Donald Trump equipped no quote
except for day one promising to seal the
southern border he is also pledged to
begin the largest deportation operation
in American history saying that migrants
are quote poisoning the blood of our
country illegal imigrants he has pledged
to round up Andel an estimated 11
million undocumented immigrants
what do you make of that
plan I think it's completely
predictable I mean look he's made it
very clear there's no mystery to what he
wants to do he started off his campaign
by saying I am your
retribution ago he said I your voice I
think he doesn't get that Americans like
he hasn't understood the poll margin who
now wants to be back as president he's
winning the primary exact retribution on
anyone who has disagreed with them any
Chris a Democrat he's on stage being
like I
represent polies he's talking about are
about just tweeted a minute ago
something good at the first debate Bas
my three colleagues on this stage when
asked if he would be convicted of
federal felonies they still support him
raised their hand looked into the camera
and let everybody know that they would
still support him even if convicted of
feral felonies Federal felonies by
majority
our involveed the most sensitive of our
governmental Secrets Federal felonies
where he instructed others to commit
crimes folks who are now agreeing to go
to jail because of what they did in his
name so do I think he was kidding when
he said he was a dictator all you have
to do is look at the history and that's
why failing to speak out against him
making excuses for him pretending that
somehow he's a victim empowers him you
want to know why those po numbers are
where they are because folks like these
three guys on the stage make it seem
like his conduct is acceptable let me
make it
clear does he not get that the majority
of Republican voters like Trump what's
he what's he trying to make clear I his
conduct is unacceptable he's unfit and
be careful of what you're going to get
if you ever got another Donald Trump
term he's letting you know I am your
retribution
only be his own retribution he doesn't
care for the American I don't care
either 58% Governor D and then
after thank you Governor DeSantis Donald
Trump would be older on day one of his
second presidency than Joe Biden was on
day one of his first have Trump is not
the same man he was when he ran in 2016
your campaign is running ads showing
Trump confused and you have said he has
quote lost the zip on his fast ball you
seem to be saying Donald Trump is no
longer mentally fit to be president is
that what you think look he he is
showing father time is undefeated the
idea that we're going to put someone up
there that's almost 80 and there's going
to be no effects from that we all know
that that's not true uh and so we have
an opportunity to do a next generation
of leaders and really be able to move
this country before we also need a
president that can serve two terms uh I
don't think Donald Trump I think he's
going to have I don't think he be able
get elected the Democrats want him to be
the nominee we see that they are going
to turn the screws the minute if he got
the nomination think Mally to be I think
we need to have somebody younger I think
when you get up to 80 I don't think it's
a job for that but let me just respond
to some of the things there look the
media is making a big deal about what he
said about some of these comments I
would just remind people uh that is not
how he governed he didn't even fire Dr
fouchy he didn't fire Christopher Ray he
didn't clean up the swamp he said he was
going to drain it he did not drain it he
said he was going to build a wall and
have Mexico pay for it we don't have the
wall uh he did say in 2016 he'd have the
largest deportation program in history
he deported less than Barack Obama did
when Barack Obama was President so some
of some of these policies he ran on in
16 I was cheering him on then but he
didn't deliver it here's what I can
promise people 100% of the things I
promised as Governor I delivered on
those promises I beat the left time and
time again and that's what I'll do
President we got to start winning again
as a party yes win the
but we've got to start getting these
issues I will go in and wreak havoc on
this bureaucracy you will see people
fired and we are going to bring a
reckoning for how this government
handled I'm bringing a
reing you had your chance to eloquin on
Donald Trump you doing whole why didn't
he just answer the question the question
was very
direct is he fit to be president or
isn't he the rest of the speech is
interesting but Democrat up there
ruin the de Itself by talking about the
de would strike the answer because
you're not answering it you have your
you have your thing is no I don't have
my thing he's the thing is he to do
talking about him being 80 years old
does mean that somebody get elected
that's
people they zoomed in on Ron's face did
you see
that
the party likes Donald Trump Donald
Trump is winning and Chris chrisy is
attacking Donald Trump on stage where
Ronda santz is even trying to avoid
going too heavy score on a test but I
know this want be we have an opportunity
to nominate someone and elect someone
for two terms who's going to be spitting
Nails on day one and for years
deliver is running for a cabinet demat
who's almost 80 years old afraid to
answer no I'm not he's no you have to
either either you're afraid or you're
not listening
simple you know look ladies please I'm a
simple guy
okay and I answer calm down is he or
isn't I'll con see fit Ron you're a new
generation you're 44 years old I wish I
was still 44 years old okay 45 so well
congratulations I'd still take
45 is he fit or isn't he and this is the
problem with my three
colleagues they're afraid to offend
divor tell you something if you're
afraid if you're afraid to offend Donald
Trump then what are you going to do when
you sit across from president X you sit
across from the ayatola you sit across
from Putin you have to be willing to
offend with the truth and
answer I promise understand just a
minute and not a
minute it's about pointing out do you
want to elect somebody who will be older
than Biden was when he went in 2021 yes
I I don't think he was he's as bad as
Biden was at all but I do think that
over a fouryear period it is not a job
for somebody that's pushing 80 we need
somebody that's younger we need that's
going to be able to go in there Donald
Trump is fit to be president I kind of
think I can run two terms thank you have
a nice
dayes on this debate stage is all three
of them have been licking Donald Trump's
boots for years for money and
endorsements Ronda Sanz you've been a
great Governor but you would have never
been without I don't think point you
attack hyoc same with Chris Christie as
a lobbyist begging them for covid money
for his special interests in New Jersey
prepping him for the debates last time
around these people are now Monday
morning quarterbacking some decision he
made I think the real enemy is not
Donald Trump it's not even Joe Biden it
is the Deep state that at least Donald
Trump attempted to take on and if you
want somebody who's going to speak truth
to power then vote for somebody who's
going to speak the truth to you why am I
the only person on the stage at least
who can say that January 6th now does
look like it was an inside job subject
here we go years about Saudi Arabia's
involvement in
that the great replacement theory is not
some Grand right-wing conspiracy theory
but a basic statement of the democratic
party's platform that the 2020 election
was indeed stolen by big Tech that the
2016 election the one that Trump won for
sure was also one that was stolen from
him by the National Security
establishment that actually put up the
Trump Russia collusion they there's a
reason why I'm the only person on the
stage who can say these things that's
what it's going to take not people who
were licking his boots one time and now
Monday morning quarterbacking
criticizing also sucks up to the that's
not his point though he's pointing out
they they were
sucking they're kissing his boots but
now turning on him trying to steal and
standing out of going to turn against
him too surgeries done on miners involve
cutting off body parts at a time when
these kids cannot even legally smoke a
cigarette kids who go from puberty
blockers to cross sex hormones are at a
much greater likelihood of winding up
sterile
how is it that you think a parent should
be able to okay these surgeries never
mind the sterilization of a child and
aren't you way too out of step on this
issue to be the Republican nominee no
what no I'm not because I because
Republicans believe in less government
not more and less involvement with
government not more in government
involvement in people's lives and you
know what
Megan I trust parents oh man dud we
should Empower parents in education we
should Empower parents make more
decisions about where their kids go to
school I agree we should Empower parents
to be teaching the values that they
believe in in their homes without the
government telling them what those
values should be and yet we want to take
other parental rights away I'm sorry as
a father of four I believe there is no
one who loves my children more than me
and if they want who loves my children
more than my wife there's no one who
cares more about their success and
health in life than we do not some
government bureaucrat not some you look
at these Jokers down in Congress it
takes them three weeks to pick a speaker
and up until two days ago they couldn't
promote somebody in the military in the
United States Senate who earned their
new Rank and we're going to put my
children's health and my decisions in
their hands for them to make those
decisions for Joe Biden to make those
decisions bro they're just saying don't
give kids sex Chang not saying anything
else this not
think it's
aent Meg and I get to make the decisions
about my children not anybody else and
every parent out there who's watching
tonight you start to turn over just a
little bit of this Authority The
Authority they're going to take from you
next you're not going to like stand up
for parents each and every time I want
the government stepping in when I got my
belt
out no he's got a sack of sweet Valencia
oranges you guys are going to
get my want his off thinks be when you
were governor in 2017 you signed a law
that required new guidelines for schools
dealing with transgender students those
guidelines required schools to accept a
child's preferred gender identity even
if the Minor's parents object it and it
said that there is no Duty for schools
to notify parents if their son or
daughter changes their gender identity
allowing this serious issue to remain a
secret between the school and a child
how is any of that Pro parental
by me is absolutely that's simply not
true that's simply not true that law was
put into effect in 2018 and regulated in
2018 before I after I was office no it
no we did not Megan we did not issue
those guidelines and you're wrong about
that simply wrong I have stood up each
and every time so I think if this is one
issue that's disqualifying it's this one
I stood up every single time for parents
to be able to make the decisions for
their minor children parents every
single time parents should make those
decisions and by the way you know what
every once in a while parents are going
to make decision polio 2017 Chris
Christie signs Bill to
extend rights away from parents he is
lying you don't know that slippery slope
what rights are going to be taken away
next and what's going to as a parent you
do not have the right to abuse your kids
this is cutting off their genitals o
this is mutilating these miners these
are irreversible procedures uh and this
is something that other countries in
Europe like
Sweden they saw it did incalculable
damage they've shut it down sign
legislation in Florida Banning the
mutilation of minors because it is wrong
we cannot allow this to happen in this
country and and I know Chris disagrees
with me and I think he has an honest
position uh Nikki disagrees with me she
opposes the bill that we did to ban that
she said law shouldn't get involved it
you said thew get also I think and this
is flows from what she did as governor
of South Carolina you they had a bill
try to say that men should go into girls
bathrooms and she killed that bill and
she bragged that she killed that bill
even to this day she Bragg that I don't
think men should be going into little
girls' bathrooms I think it's wrong and
I think we have every right to protect
them from
that I I I am going to come to you I I
promis him a seconds go quickly I think
the North Star here is transgenderism is
is a mental health disorder we don't let
you smoke a cigarette by the age of 18
we don't let you have an addictive drink
of alcohol by the age of 21 and I just
challenge Ron Des sis to go one step
further and support what I think is
clearly within the authority to do using
federal funds just like Reagan did in 84
for the highway act that said the
minimum drinking age needs to be 21 we
can do the same thing when it comes to
Banning genital mutilation or chemical
castration I know Ron's been that on the
federal level I'm Crystal Clear that's
where I stand that's a mental health
disorder that's where we need to be at
go
ahead it is literally a disorder Ron has
continued to lie because he's losing
it's not a lie you are lying on tape so
first of all I will say that when I was
governor 10 years ago when the bathroom
situation came up I we had maybe a
handful of kids that were dealing with
an issue and I said we don't need to
bring government into this but go into
boys bathrooms girls go into girls
bathrooms and if anyone else has an
issue they use a private bathroom now 10
years later we see that this issue has
exploded and this shows how hypocritical
Ron continues to be when he was running
for governor and they asked him about
that he said he didn't think bathroom
bills were a good use of his time you
can go look that up I signed a bathroom
bill in Florida I believe Ron Ron's a
culture Warrior
it's the only thing he's got these are
his issues the idea that you would say
that I was sign you didn't you killed it
I signed it I st for little girls you
didn't do it and there was this going I
was actually just in South Carolina some
of the legislators told me at the time
there were boys going into the girls
that's the whole reason why they did it
and so they say when she does that
explanation that that doesn't hold water
and this is the upstate of South
Carolina I signed the bill I protected
the girl car did not do know Carol car
no no no you are not going to talk about
my state like that because I will tell
you for fact South Carolinians never
allowed that to happen and we hadn't we
did not have that issue at the time what
I have always said is boys going to a
boys bathroom girls going to a girls
bathroom but hold on one second I also
say that biological boys shouldn't be
playing in girls Sports and I will do
everything I can to stop that because
it's the women's issue of our
time govern Carol way more Trump more
based than she to move
on when discussing your Hindu faith in
September you seem to take a shot at
Ambassador Haley who was also
indian-american and who converted to
Christianity as an adult you said an
easy thing for me to do being a
politician is to shorten my name profess
to be a Christian and then run make VI
Vicki or whatever end quote are you
questioning Nikki Haley's Christian
convictions and why is your campaign
made a point of referring to Ambassador
Haley by her given first name nimada
even though she has gone by Nikki for
her whole life well my whole deal is if
Nikki Haley of all people should know
how to pronounce my name correctly the
rest of the news media can learn it my
deal is I'll call her Nikki which he can
say my own name right that's our little
fun side bet there here's what I will
say is deeper I don't question her faith
but I question her authenticity and I
think that's deeper here we were just
talking about the trans issue this is a
symptom of a deeper cancer in American
Life identity politics this new Rel says
your your gender and your sexuality are
your identity it is anti-an it isocratic
it's anti meritocratic and it is
dividing this country to a Breaking
Point and I've spoken about this to the
left my books are all about this I've
preached this to the left but it's even
worse when Republicans try to play the
same game we're talking about that trans
issue in Nikki Haley's campaign launch
video sounded like a woke Dylan mulany
Bud Light ad talking about how she would
kick in heels at the first debate she
said that only a woman can get this job
done that's what she said after the
third debate when I criticized R
McDaniel after five failed years of
leadership of this party and criticized
Nikki for her corrupt foreign dealings
as a military contractor she said that I
have a woman problem Nikki I don't have
a woman problem you have a corruption
problem Nikki is
corrupt Save Your Kids To Die who oh my
God that was actually it that was a real
thing this is the problem I tweeted that
thing that somebody sent out and I
thought that was a joke I thought
photosho he did it on
purpose sh this is how this game The
Puppet Masters put up their puppet and I
re he's doing that right now because he
wants it to be a
meme everyone know his name and I'm sick
and tired of the double standards people
that was amazing my buddy sent me a
picture of the tweet I thought was
photosho I thought phot like this like
10 minutes ago resp I thought it was
photoshopped and it's real but that's
that's not him holding up that's
overhead shot of him
preparing
know it's like holy cow question that
was to you okay we got to move on to
this I love this with the rep I'm phot
something right now actually for about
the justice department and our election
system here's Tom fitten with Judicial
Watch let's just talk about V crushing
Nikki can we please talk about that
please V crushing Nikki no that's uh
president Trump and many of his
supporters
claim agenes have abused his civil
rights for the last years by among other
things spying on him and now Prosecuting
him while having treated Hillary Clinton
and Joe Biden with kid gloves a recent
Gallop poll shows that Americans think
more highly of the US Postal Service
than they do the FBI or justice
department what would you do as
president to restore the faith of the
American people in these agencies
well first off I'm the only person on
this stage who's actually done a job in
the Department of Justice I was the US
attorney in New Jersey in the fifth
largest office in this country appointed
by President Bush on September 10th 2001
okay and it was an extraordinary time in
this country to be on the front lines of
fighting the greatest attack against our
country since Pearl Harbor and I'm proud
of the seven years I spent in the
justice department and one of the
reasons I am is because I had an
attorney general when I came in named
John Ashcraft and John Ashcraft stood up
and told each and every one of us our
job was to do one thing to make sure
Justice was done every day regardless of
partisanship regardless of gender or
race or any other consideration and
that's what we did for seven years and
at a time when our country was at its
greatest moment of danger in the last 40
years we did exactly that and there was
not another domestic teror terrorist
attack on this soil so what I would do
as president having had that experience
and the only one who's had that
experience is to pick an attorney
general who will absolutely do the same
thing that John ascra did to pick us
attorneys who will only care about
making sure that Justice is done without
regard to any other consideration but
the facts that are presented and whether
someone is guilty Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt and the government can prove it we
have had attorneys General like Eric
Holder and Loretta Lynch and Jeff
sessions and now our current attorney
general who have not met that standard
and the only way you restore people's
faith in the justice system is to put
someone like that in charge of the
justice department and then as president
to get at the hell out of the way on
anything that involves criminal
investigations if a president's involved
in trying to do something and put their
thumb on the scales Donald Trump says he
will do shut up that makes
people system be
fair
I many Republicans are concerned about
the legitimacy of Elections a federal
judge just
redn must count on dated mail-in ballots
and unlike Alabama many states still
don't require any identification to vote
what should states do now to increase
election integrity and voter confidence
for the 24 election block well Tom
thanks for the question thanks for you
guys do a Judicial Watch it's really
really important there's a lot of
corruption in this government you guys
are doing a great job what you should do
election integrities do what we did in
Florida 20 years ago Florida and
elections was a joke everybody would
laugh at it uh I came in I removed a
couple supervisors from South Florida we
require voter ID Universal no Zucker
bucks no Mass mail balloting and no
ballot harvesting we even have an agency
that prosecutes people uh for violating
election laws the result of that in both
2020 and 2022 we counted millions and
millions of votes on Election night
produced the results it was transparent
and everybody was happen that is not
happening throughout this country let me
tell you this as the nominee I think
it's important not every State's where
we need it to be there is ballot
harvesting in places like Nevada all
these places I am not going to fight
with one hand tied behind my back I'm
going to have organizations in all the
swing States if they're harvesting we're
harvesting if there're Zucker bucks
we're Zucker bucks we are going to
exploit whatever the rules are I favor
changing the rules to be like Florida
and some of the other states that have
done a good job but until then we have
to do that and then just on the justice
department and FBI I mean I remember
being uh you know in Iraq working with
FBI on the ground and being uh and then
I was a Special Assistant I used to have
such a high regard for these agencies
what they did to Donald Trump with the
Russia collusion was one of the biggest
abuses of power in the history of our
country
these agencies need to be cleaned out
with me you'll have a new FBI director
on day one uh we're going to clear out
the doj the IRS all these places buckle
your seat belts there's going to be a
new sheriff in town
all back in one minute good one up next
just once got
got photos using my phone that blew my
mind dude so like Josh my buddy
downstairs was like he sent me the
picture of the meme of that of the whole
you know Haley's corrupt I thought it
was literally photosho so you had like
an aerial shot of it yeah there was like
overhead shot I retweeted and I like
literally thought it was like oh it's
like oh somebody photo you know he wants
it and then he holds up holy for a
long time stood there and had the
correct angle multiple CER to become a
meme Grandpa how did Nikki Haley's
political career end uh just show that
picture like crush it bro yeah I am
curious to see what the polls are like
tomorrow because Chris Christie's barely
here I mean he's not talking at all and
in fact there was a whole segment where
they never even tossed him a question I
couldn't even hear him breathing over
the mic either so no no you couldn't and
so in then you have Nikki Haley who she
is holding a pretty steady position in
New Hampshire but again will this shake
it enough to put you know I would be
really curious right now it doesn't look
like vake would win New Hampshire it
looks like Donald Trump will win Iowa
and New Hampshire but I wonder who that
second place will be will that be enough
there you go yeah that's what I was
picturing I hope that goes on Twitter
should I
tweet yeah I I don't know big 2024 truth
tweet tweet it really big with the word
truth all in caps the vake and uh I got
to fix your camera there Ian I just saw
there you know you know you know what I
will do though a funny so for those that
are wondering I just I I'm using my
phone here to um edit this this
wonderful uh VI photo and I I I I drew a
a male genitals on his all of them on
his notep no but what I will do is I'm
going to post I post I'm going to erase
what he wrote and post the blank white
notepad oh that's a good idea that's a
good idea yeah create systems create
systems I will I will unleash it unto
you and I will not post the vulgarity
myself I take no responsibility for yeah
David Robinson in chat feels that one uh
he had the image the uh so christe said
how he would get restore faith in the in
the FBI was to replace what was it the
Attorney General yeah they also like
clear out the know the front office so
to speak I feel like he could have
punched harder at the Biden
Administration like I the thing is Trump
is dominating this they're all
critiquing Trump's record he was the
last Republican president but they could
all be attacking Joe Biden for all kinds
of things because those will be the
immediate problems they take on when if
if anyone theoretically not that I think
any of them are going to get the elected
but whoever is elected next is going to
take on the the legacy of Joe Biden and
he has left a lot of messes behind him
like he is a destructive president in so
many ways let's just just talk about the
Border all of them have interesting and
strong fairly strong positions the
Border way stronger than Republicans
have been in the past but it's not
enough right they need to talk more
directly about what Biden is not doing
also that the Trump didn't build the
wall thing I don't think it was a
one-term job it's like a three 16 years
you know it could take a long time and
reinforcement there was there was
obstruction and when several border
states started building their own
barriers the federal government under
Biden came and took them down oh yeah do
you remember when they they import their
voters one way or another du out of
Arizona to take he had these um shipping
containers in the gaps and they like you
have to take those down they're in
federal land or something like that you
like okay are you going to put a wall up
and they're like but no the the animals
migrate through here there's one thing
as well when you mentioned there where
they when like Chrissy talks about
saying hey clean out doj and it comes
down like well you know for example one
of my close friends from the Navy who's
now been in the FBI for about 15 almost
15 years now you know he's kind of the
same mind he is very based in many ways
but also at the same time he kind of
looks at it as he's worried about this
like throw the baby out with the bathat
kind of a thing and you know I'm more
than M like no you need to like make
some very disruptive changes as in like
breaking it up right like like has
happen a lot of folks you know I'm not
saying like look and one thing we have
to realize though is like the phrase we
had when I was in the service it's
called you know one a ruins a
thousand out of boys right because guess
what like the FBI does do a lot of
really good work they stop drug dealers
you know child Predators they do actual
real work but the thing is though was
like look when there are like these
massive fails and not even fails but
like evil bad things that the you know
that federal law enforcement are doing
it's like you like that does not that
negates all the good work it's got to be
split up and it's got to be like it's
can be divvied out to different agencies
state level Federal level but it's way
too powerful if you read about how the
uh FBI started it's wild oh yeah J Edgar
hoop like his personal military or
something wild I don't know much about
it oh yeah oh we're back and this girl
House Republicans yesterday hauled Elite
University presidents up to Capitol Hill
to answer for the displays of
anti-Semitism on college campuses they
all defended it these leaders including
the president of Harvard were asked
whether calling for the genocide of the
Jews would violate school policies
against harassment and
intimidation all of them said it would
depend on the context including whether
that speee veers into
conduct how do you think these schools
and the rest of society should balance
the imperative of free speech against
the need to prevent radical activists
from harassing and intimidating others
it was disgusting to see what happened
you know if this had been the KKK that
was doing protests on those campuses
every one of those College presidents
would have been up in arms y this is
just as bad the idea that they would go
and allow that kind of pramas protest or
agree with the genocide of Jews and try
and say that they needed context on that
there is no context to that this is what
we need to do to deal allow protest
protest got to get foreign money out of
our universities you've got Arab Money
you've got Chinese money you've got
others we need to go to Every University
and say you either take foreign money or
you take American money but the days of
taking both are over the second thing we
need to do already getting
the already got one my buddy just said
from downstairs there's one in Super
Chat I can't say it though you don't
think that Israel has a right to exist
that is anti-Semitic we will change the
definition so that every government
every school has to acknowledge the
definition for what it is the third
thing is we really do need to ban Tik
Tock once and for all and let me tell
you why for every 30 minutes that
someone watches Tik Tok every day they
become 177% more anti-semitic more
promas based on doing
we now know 50% of adults to 25 we do
know that
t what they did with Israel that's a
problem when campuses also don't go and
protect when they have these rallies and
you've got students that are scared we
need to go to these universities and say
if you're not going to protect these
students if you're not going to
acknowledge anti-Semitism we'll take
your tax exempt status away that'll fix
it and that'll take care of it for
good stay with you Ambassador Haley
on October 6th the Israeli government
thought it had a cleare eyed view of the
threat from
Hamas according to the New York Times it
even had hamas's attack plan and
dismissed it as an aspiration the
Israelis were wrong in our country the
FBI director told the Senate panel just
yesterday that he sees quote blinking
red lights everywhere and that the
Threat Level has quote gone to a whole
another level since October 7th which of
the threats facing our country do you
worry could Blindside us what worries me
and what keeps me up at night is what
happens between now and election day
while Joe Biden's in office that's what
worries me more than anything else but
I'll tell you that America right now is
acting like it's September 10th we
better remember what September 12th felt
like because it only takes one and
whether you're looking at open borders
that are allowing people to come in Iran
knows the easiest way to get to America
through the southern border and we're
not doing anything to stop it we've got
to get the foreign infiltration out of
our country whether it's in our schools
whether it's on our social media whether
it's we need to stop all foreign
lobbying that's happening to members of
Congress and we need to start securing
America again until we do that we are
going to be at threats we've got to look
at Iran China and Russia want to destroy
the I was in the Senate today saw again
we' got to start protecting Americans
right now Americans don't protect and
we're not doing anything to strengthen
it so Biden continues to be a problem
that'll change on Election
Day Governor de
santz if China invades Taiwan would you
send American troops as President Biden
has said he would do we will be able to
deter that from happening I think that's
the important thing we need a strategy
of denial so that we're deterring X's
Ambitions what if it does he want it's
going to work TR taiwan's an ally we
have long-standing American policy and
and and you know how that's done and we
will follow that uh but here's the thing
Taiwan is important not just because of
semiconductors it's important because if
China is able to break out of this first
island chain they're going to be able to
dominate Commerce in the entire
indopacific correct they will use that
to export authoritarianism all around
the world including here in the United
States you look at some of these guys
actually some of them that are
supporting Nikki on Wall Street they
gravel to China uh anytime something
happens they got to go do that so they
already exert a huge amount of authority
over this country it will get a lot
worse so deterring China's Ambitions is
the number one National Security uh task
that I will do as president and we will
succeed the 21st century needs to be an
American Century we cannot let it be a
Chinese Century Mr Ram we need to be
clear I'll be clear on the same issue
I'm coming to you next on Taiwan you
said if you want to stop Chi from
invading Taiwan quote let's open a
branch of the NRA in Taiwan and put an
AR-15 in the hands of every and them how
to
it a taste of American
exceptionalism the National Police in
Taiwan announced a zero gun policy last
year is this a serious policy proposal
and if it isn't why do you keep
repeating it well it's part of a broader
deterrent strategy and so I think I'm
going to respectfully disagree with Ron
here I think the next US president needs
to be crystal clear that at least for
the foreseeable future the US will
absolutely defend Taiwan and it is with
that clarity that we actually achieve
deterr have bro strategy than that we
need to get on side in our relationship
with India take it to the next level
India has to be able to block the
Andaman sea which is where China gets
most of its Middle Eastern Oil supplies
that's critical I also do believe the
Second Amendment is a critical way of
preventing foreign autocrats from being
able to it's worked in America why
wouldn't it work in Taiwan so it is part
of a broader strategy but I do think
that we need to be specific about our
deterrent strategy or else xiin ping is
just encroaching by the day and the
reason why we're not doing it for China
I want to be Crystal Clear is because
we're scared why are we scared because
we depend on them for our modern way of
life why do we depend on them for our
modern way of life it's because Nikki
Haley's latest friends like Larry
thinkink have created co-mingled
economies with black rocktel and Exxon
and Chevron they can't drill here while
being a shareholder of Petrina not
applying those same constraints in China
so it is our economic dependence on
China that makes us scared if that were
a Russian spy balloon we'd have shot it
down an instant correct if that were a
Russian spy Base in Cuba we'd be turning
the we'd be we'd be actually going hard
on them instead of turning the other way
as we are with China so it comes back
down to that economic dependence we
cannot depend on them for our
Pharmaceuticals our semiconductors and
people have been lied to for a long time
our own military the F35 jets that we
make in this country depend on China and
it's going to take an outsider to fix
that broke and establish thank you Mr
ramaswami Ambassador H you should come
back with like if every 30 minutes kids
on Tik Tok
we win in Ukraine that we protect our
friends but also let China know that
they'll be if they go into Taiwan they
need to know that there is going to be a
force that's going to go against them
and they need to know it's not just
going to be the United States that is
why we need to build our Partnerships
with India with South Korea with Japan
with the Philippines with Australia we
need to start pulling that Alliance
together and the first way we do that is
we need to make sure that on day one we
look at the fact whatever if China
pulled the rug out from under us
tomorrow would we be ready think about
what happened during folks everybody
told you to wear a mask they were made
in China everybody told you to take a
covid tests they were made in China
everybody went and I mean everything
that happened if you go to the drugstore
all those medicines are made in China we
have to make sure that we are not
relying on China for
any went over to the desk
focus
on I should be the moderator Governor
christe I'd like you to on that do you
think
with15 I don't think we have
constitutional authority over Taiwan to
give them a second amendment I think
they can only do that for themselves but
look he went over there B I want be
really clear once again I want to play
the role of actually answering your
question which is if China went after
you're absolutely right I asent have us
go militarily and defend them um
secondly I'm not AF too based upon those
economic relationships to do that
because these economic relationships
mean nothing nothing if what's going to
happen is that China is going to come
and act in that region of the world
however they see fit it's not right and
and and I'll say this about um what you
know I heard from Nikki
earlier she said that Donald Trump was
good on
trade he wasn't and the proof that he
wasn't good on trade with China is that
all he did was impose tariffs which
raise the prices for every American you
want to know what has contributed want a
position in a Democrat Administration
yes it's more government spending the
Democrat wins says we're going to be
bipartisan and unify the Country
Republican bring in prices that were
driven by Donald
Trump Ed Trump can't say he was good on
trade cuz he didn't trade he didn't
change one Chinese policy in the process
he failed on it thank you Governor
Christie governor DeSantis switching
subjects here for 15 years Republicans
have been burned by politicians promises
to repeal Obamacare Trump repeatedly
promised to replace it with quote
something terrific but failed to propose
anything you're now promising something
better but Florida has more uninsured
people than almost any other state why
should Americans trust you more than any
other Republicans who've disappointed
them on this issue well I think we have
millions of Americans who do not have
access to Affordable Health Care and
it's not just getting some type of card
and Medicaid because a lot of times they
don't even get access to doctors do you
actually get access to care uh the other
thing is we have millions and millions
of people don't have access to good
doctors and good hospitals Florida did
not expand Obamacare I think the states
that did that uh I think are struggling
financially so that yes we declin to do
that and I don't think that that was the
right policy to do uh but we are going
to go after the cost you're paying too
much for everything we've actually
addressed this in Florida in some ways
but you need price transparency you need
to hold the Pharmaceuticals accountable
you need to hold big insurance and big
government accountable and we're going
to get that done I think it's very very
important economically I think it's very
very important for for the country that
we get that done go ahead yes so I
actually wanted to this is a very
personal issue to our family I wanted to
take actually a minute to recognize my
wife who's here today
badass surgeon she did a bunch of cases
with cancer survivors earlier today flew
here to be tonight we'll be back at 7:00
a.m. in Columbus Ohio tomorrow taking
care of those patients in the O and on
the front lines of people who have
actually not swallowed for years and
here's what something that's awful
that's happening in our Healthcare
System they'll pay for anything like
feeding tubes doctors to be pill pushers
but for the procedures that can actually
make these patients better we have a
broken healthare system that doesn't pay
for for it my wife a poville in many
cases does not get paid for those
procedures she does them anyway because
it's the right thing to do but that does
not work systemwide so here's the answer
tell you about we don't have a Health
Care system in this country we have a
sick care system we need to start having
diverse Insurance options in a
competitive Marketplace that cover
actual Health preventative medicine diet
exercise lifestyle and otherwise how we
deler
that
that's where the competitive
market that's the multiple times
successful I mean he do have any politic
Trump Administration and Private
Industry developed a covid vaccine in
record time
comp can't talk about vaccine apparently
on Rumble wait okay that's that's not us
that's them that's that was aoke them
yeah oh technical issu dude seriously as
soon as they start talking about
vaccines come on guys
just explained how to solve it he said
that you need to end the antitrust
exemptions on the
pharmaceutical on the insurance agency
wait wait waitd what she has asking
about vaccines and the whole thing just
shut down dude that's some stra Chris
from crumble don't make me want to put
on tinfoil hat guys but like come on
this like I said if it was YouTube I'd
be like oh that makes sense I mean we
are on YouTube so you end the
antitrust right back for insurance
agencies that's pretty cool I like I
like the music though yeah Jam
VI you know what the music makes it all
the music makes it okay of all those
folks on stage I got to say the things
you think about like the GU VI right
like tremendous private sector
experience right and his wife super
accomplished too like you know it's one
those things you compare him in terms of
like Legacy like what they've done
before like like politician compared to
someone who you know like started huge
companies he's a billionaire or I don't
know if he's a billionaire he's a nine
fig dude at least like that is that's
that's pretty hard to do yeah it is I
think often about I'm not qualified to
get into politics yet cuz I haven't done
jack with my personal like I I
guess I have it's what's going on I know
it's wild dude okay but what if it's not
the the vaccine thing what if like Chris
Christie finally stormed off stage or
like fell over knows I don't know yo but
no but for real like what if something
happen is this is this airing somewhere
else well right now well online this is
It's on Rumble like if you want to watch
on television we could well I'm not
saying you should pull it up but just
like let's make sure it's like it's not
it's not a r
it's a rumble problem and not a
know yeah this is their stream so right
now looking into it from what I can see
but like if if other folks are airing it
looks like looks like TV is still on
yeah okay okay so if you're watching on
on cable you're you're still getting it
Chris Christie he's what wait he's he's
eating the
microphone I'm kidding he's he charged
the camera he's like I'm tired of this
the entire idea oh no what Austin
Peterson tweets vi just hammered the
final in the neocon coffin era tonight I
want to rewat suspense what did he say
but the idea of like any politician
right who's coming out there where it's
like this guy like V and Trump for that
for that matter they don't need the job
right he does not need to be here right
A lot of these folks here that's how
they make their money mhm I can't
believe they just lost the the debate
the thing is everyone on stage needs to
be here to raise their National profile
on some level and that's and that's
totally understandable that's why they
were invented in the first place right
so Americans could get the candidates
but it is a weird stage when ultimately
we know I like I wonder if Trump is
waiting until there's basically one left
and then he's like okay I'll do a debate
now like he doesn't need to be here
while they throw punches at each other
but we all ultimately want to know how
he how whoever comes out of this Stacks
up against Trump if I got to say if he's
still maintaining the ridiculously
strong lead he has no he has no
incentive to it's like well that's what
he said he was like it's all downside
right and and the GOP needs him more
because he's essentially a headliner
right if he goes they're like it's
ridiculous to skip this that was Ron
McDaniel's but he would boost all of
their ratings are we back is that going
on when anyone asks who lost the debate
tonight the answer is Rumble ouch I know
it sucks cuz I love Rumble I mean I just
refreshed it and now it's just doing
this the trip counter of Joe Biden and
versus rub HQ tripping all over the here
we go here we go oh no oh you're
rewinding oh crap yeah I hope it picks
so they just switched to they just cut
to some trips from okay yeah they switch
to some they're like remember how much
you don't like Joe Biden it's fine get
your exclusive
the bid blooper real now they're selling
the elep I do feel like they're not
talking about Biden enough I think that
there's a lot of infighting which makes
sense as a Republican primary but like I
said they're going to inherit they're
going to inherit whatever Trump Biden
leaves oh okay I guess Rumble just lost
it I don't know I get I get annoyed when
they talk about other people is did it
go to commercial now I guess cuz they're
running commercials m i mean they must
have been pretty close to a commercial
break
anyways yeah yeah it's it's running
commcial look into right now that's all
I can see yeah Rumble just everyone at
Rumble they're all jumping through their
asses trying to figure it out I'm sure
but but I think it went to commercial
anyway so like I said I I'm pretty sure
they were close to a Breakin still but
right when they're talking vaccine stuff
just a little weird yeah yeah but Rumble
Rumble I'm with you I think it's is that
armless Palmer uh they they don't make
those
anymore cuz liquid death got sued my um
so just a shout out to uh now it's
called Dead billionaire the the best one
of the best mil guys out there on mil
Twitter so if you guys are out there a
guy named Commander salamander who I CDR
salamander strongly recommend on any
sort of like military special Naval
issues he's a retired naval officer uh
friend who I know in real life but he
maintains himself very an on uh anyways
he was like tweeting at me he's like
what's that can that Tom has right now
he's watching right now so hey Sal and
so yeah it's a liquid death and it's a
limited edition and obviously
discontinued so yeah it's actually
called uh I think it's not dead
billionaire it's dead golfer okay de
billionaire oh wow but to the friends
who anybody watching right now uh and
here just anything military on Twitter
uh Commander salamander CDR salamander
uh 10 out of 10 recommend awesome I just
followed him do you talk to a lot of
people who don't use Twitter like how
often do you oh yeah oh a ton I mean
that's like my family and do you feel
like they exist in a different world and
you we were this the other yeah
generally oh yeah my yeah lot my mom's
always asking me like oh did you watch
this on it's like no I don't watch Fox
but you have all sorts of information
that they probably don't have yeah I
mean like it's one thing also a lot of
us who are like very online right
especially on political cultural issues
you got to realize that it's like that's
a pretty Niche You Know Field you know
yeah and you know outside of folks like
even when I mentioned oh I'm going on
this podcast tomorrow blah blah blah
like you know a lot of folks the folks
who are like following politics or
online watching things they all know
this yeah but a lot of folks like oh
I've heard of that I'm like I like oh
Tim P you heard about him he used to
work for vice he used to do this this
this you know Occupy Wall Street but way
back in the day like oh yeah I think but
a lot like a lot of the normies you know
they they don't follow Twitter they
don't know what's going on so how do you
feel like that will affect with the 2024
election because there is I think even
more than 2016 more than 2020 a division
between people who are online and see
one thing and actual you know not even
like lefties who are offline like just
moderate voters who don't exist in this
space I think they're actually okay this
is just me guessing and I could be wrong
and I'm trying to like set my own biases
aside I think they're actually more
based than we think I I believe that I I
believe that I feel like the left has
dragged the barometer so far over that
they point to the middle and say you're
far right cthulu always swims left right
you know if you you know follow Curtis
yarvin stuff at all how cthulu always
swims to the left one of his flippers
are bigger than the other right well
yeah but it's just always that way one
of the things I've always said is
politics always flows left yeah and what
that means is if an antifa guy stands
next to a trump supporter and a
photograph they're both rightwing right
or does that mean Pol yeah politics only
flows to the right I don't know it flows
in One Direction well yeah take your
like conventional like mainstream
well-known conserve like uh like your
Ben Shapiro right for instance right who
we would consider right you transport
him back in time 100 years he's a wacko
Lefty right you know what I mean by 1923
standards right and then if you take you
know uh somebody who's on the right from
1923 right and you transport him to
1823 he's a wacko Lefty right so it's
like always kind of swims to the left
right and then until usually some sort
of a reset you know not to get all like
so does that me you feel like we're
approaching you feel like we're
approaching a reset period if you feel
like the moderate just I wish we weren't
but we probably are cuz yeah I mean I I
think a lot of people can agree it's
like a Vibe you whatever you want to
call it but like back we're back we're
book about President Reagan that's going
to be called what would Reagan that book
is going to come out early in
2024 here we go was that Ronald Reagan
was a slave to the truth Ronald Reagan
stood up for the truth whether it was
popular or unpopular at the moment in
1964 he stood up against the John bur
society when it was very unpopular to
the party to do it but he would not put
up with our party standing for lies and
deceit even it gave him political
progress that's the kind of president
that I will be and I would draw that
inspiration from the 40th President of
the United States Ronald Reagan
Ambassador Haley well I have to say too
I think George Washington when you look
at the responsibilities he had AAL how
do you go and take on Great American
experiment and make sure that the people
are protected and they always knew that
government was intended to secure the
rights and freedoms of the people it was
never meant to be all things to all
people and then you look at Abraham
Lincoln and you look at the challenges
and you look at the division that
happened in our country and the ability
to lead in spite of the loud noises why
she talk her teeth like what will bring
out the
best
we need that now she's she doesn't open
her mou when she talks she's talking
like
this excellent uh one of the guys I'll
take inspiration from is Calvin kulage
now people don't talk about him a lot
he's one of the few
President right he understood the proper
role of the Federal Government under the
Constitution we need to restore the US
Constitution as the centerpiece of our
national life and that requires a
president who understands the original
understanding of the Constitution who
has a good sense of the Bill of Rights
and who knows how we've gone off track
with this massive fourth branch of
government uh this administrative state
which is imposing its will on us and is
being weaponized against us So Silent
Cal knew the proper role of the Federal
Government the country was in great
shape when when he was president of the
United States and we can earn learn a
lawful lot from Calvin kulage over to
you well great thanks foring in well I
will say Ron picked a president who was
born on July 4th I'll pick one who died
on July 4th it's Thomas Jefferson he was
33 years old when he wrote the
Declaration of Independence and you all
are sitting on a swivel chair today he
invented the swivel chair while he was
at it while writing that Declaration of
Independence that's that founding spirit
that we miss that we're the Pioneers
we're the Explorers the guy who sent him
out on the Lewis and Clark Expeditions
and I think a lot about what would
Thomas Jefferson say to today's
Republican party and I think one thing
he us we haven't talked about as much
tonight but I think it is one of the
interesting ideological discussions
we're having in our party is freedom of
speech you get to express your mind
freely no matter how heinous the opinion
Thomas Jefferson understood that he's an
inspiration for me thank you Mr ramas
Swami and believe it or not it's time
for closing statements Governor Christie
would you like to begin sure thank you I
want you all to kind of picture in your
mind's election day oh God you'll all be
heading to the polls to vote he's going
to say and that's something that Donald
Trump will
not because he will be convicted of
felonies before then and his right to
vote will be taken away you know does he
not understand the base likes him here's
the bottom line you can boo about it all
you like and continue to deny reality
but if we deny reality as a party we're
going to have four more years of Joe
Biden when I my colleagues here rais
their hands and said they would support
him even if he was a convicted felon the
bigger problem with it is they were
confirming the LIE
Amic people if you're too timid to take
on Trump believe me others will get will
see that
timidity Putin and the Ayatollah the
Border crossers on the southern border
and the criminals in our streets they'll
sense that timidity and they'll take
advantage of that failure leadership
struggles to talk we need to get back to
an old American idea that every person
is responsible for their own even a
president bre take I'll be the kind of
president who has the humility that
that you work for the people a treadmill
we'll talk about it way
around I will earn your trust I want to
earn your vote thank you Governor
Christie Mr
ramaswami iuse this to just address a
topic we didn't talk about tonight but I
think is one of the most important
topics that needs to be discussed ideas
that is this climate change agenda that
is shackling this country like a set of
handcuffs I said it the first debate and
I stand by it the climate change agenda
is a hoax because it has nothing to do
with the climate that's what we have to
see 98% reduction in the climate
disaster related deaths in the last
century eight times as many people are
going to die of cold temperatures this
year than warm ones yet against that
backdrop there's an issue coming up in
Iowa it's core to Iowa Farmers I met Kim
junker Kathy Stockdale and other farmers
who are about to have a carbon capture
pipeline built across their land using
eminent domain to do it that's
unconstitutional and it's wrong and if
you thought Co was bad what's coming
with this climate agenda is far worse we
should not be bending the knee to this
new religion that is what it is it is a
substitute for a modern religion we are
fogging ourselves and losing our modern
way of life bowing to this new God of
climate and that will end on my watch
it's the most critic show that's coming
up thank
you thank you very much our country is
in chaos we see it on the southern
border we see it in our on our streets
and our cities we see it on College camp
we feel it with our economy with
inflation and with debt and world with
war in the Middle East crazy surgery or
something we have to stop the chaos but
you can't Democrat chaos Republican
chaos and that's what Donald Trump gives
us my Approach is different no drama no
vendettas no whining just War I Envision
in America where we're protected from
illegal immigration and Chinese
infiltration I Envision in America where
we unleash our economy and we reject
socialism but more importantly I
Envision in America where we ReDiscover
our national purpose and our pride I
Crush Joe Biden in the PS and if you
give me this chance we will crush him in
November and take our country maybe her
teeth are just too
bigd
the
[Applause]
no I'm wondering if she's she's feeling
like there's still one more I forgot
there's one more we are in Jeopardy
Jeopardy of being the first generation
of Americans to leave to our kids and
grandkids in America less prosperous and
less free than the one we inherited I
refuse to sit sit idly by and let that
happen but we got to have people that
are going to be willing to fight the
people that are doing this to us you
can't be these establishment Republicans
that just cave at the first sign of
opposition I'll fight for you we also
need to win again as a party yes the
election which we've struggled to do but
also win on these big issues and nobody
has defeated these people more than what
I have done in the State of Florida on
issue after issue we have won and we
have won big and that's what we'll do
for you we also need leadership
leadership is not about doing what's
easy it's about being willing to set out
that Vision knowing they're going to
shoot arrows at you they're going to
come at you I will fight the good fight
I will keep the faith and I will finish
the race thank you and God bless thank
you all of you all of you than you
guys Mike dropped man can I tell you
something if I if I may real quick is if
you guys might remember back in 2016
during the Democratic debates which was
like a hilarious like you know joke they
asked the like you know the F and
closing out arguments to say who is it
somebody that you're proud to call your
enemy right and it was like Bernie
Sanders like the NRA or somebody and
Hillary Clinton's like Republicans or
whatever and then they had you guys
remember James web you guys remember he
ran throwback he was a Senator Senator
from Virginia irginia former Secretary
of the Navy under Reagan also kind of
like one of my personal Heroes who I
looked up to as a kid Naval Academy guy
Vietnam war hero all this and what he
says it was great and there's like he
was too Bas for the Democrats he goes
the North Vietnamese infantry officer
who threw a grenade at me but he's not
around to talk about it
anymore is that the guy they named the
James Webb Telescope after no different
guy totally different James web but yeah
that when I saw that it was like oh
Democrats couldn't handle that well I
think it's I think it's clear after
watching this um a tremendous
performance by some of the candidates
and we all now know who the nominee is
going to be Donald Trump Donald Trump
thanks thanks everyone for hanging out
for two hours so that we could uh
confirm that it would be Donald Trump
but I I got to give it up I I do think
it was good I think Ron actually his
best debate performance do well I still
think he's got he's got a personality
problem for his and his campaign is
poorly run there is but there's a lot of
really great points when it comes to
cultural issues Nikki Haley lied Chris
Christie lied the most so I pulled up I
pulled the article I tweeted out from
Politico Chris Christie signed the bill
on the trans bathroom stuff and other
trans rights and other he's lying and he
knows he's in trouble yeah with that
Nikki Haley also did say parental rights
she also did say she will make it so you
can't be anonymous she's gaffed way too
much so uh you know Iran and v v
obviously took the night but I I want to
make sure I point out V is speaking to
us of course there's a lot of people
he's not speaking to sure so we saw in
his first debate performance he actually
saw uh favorability go up and
unfavorability go up sure so there were
a lot of people who didn't know who he
was and he and he polarized so yeah yeah
I mean honestly I think vake uh can you
know write his ticket in the Trump
Administration and and Chris Chrissy can
write his for the Newsome Administration
you're not wrong but I don't think the
Newsome admin I mean they would take him
just to eventually kick him out in a
dramatic way he is a republican no
Newsome is going to be like we're going
to bring Unity to this country be un we
want Republicans on our side Chris
Christie I need your help would take
like Liz Cheney because Li Cheney's
never endorsed Trump whereas um this guy
has but but I think that's the point of
what Chris G is going for unpopular
statement guys so I think it's a matter
of time before Gavin new is President
one of these days I mean he's still
relatively young you don't think so I'm
not saying I'm not saying I think he'll
campaign I'm not saying 24 no really
okay I hope I'm wrong and I hope you're
right he doesn't have it right really
you don't think so no absolutely not
he's he's a Mitt Romney Type M okay
right like the governor you know Mitt
Romney's a governor he's a senator and
then he runs for president and it's just
like m romne Joe Biden was the Mitt
Romney type he was so gross in o08 when
I was watching them debate OB the other
thing is like the Democrats have this
identity issue which is that they they
don't want white men in office anymore
so theoretically they could run Gavin
Newsome he's good on some positions he's
a white man and this is going to
continue to be one of the issue that
bifurcates the voters in that party this
is something that Joe Biden was like
hinting at during his campaign like I'll
I'll be the last of the Old Guard just
just left me this one time and now he
doesn't want to leave and if they put in
a gavan it'll be the same thing and with
Gavin I look it this way it's like Gavin
is charming he is charismatic he is
handsome and I and guess what that
matters you guys a lot more than people
are willing to admit and when people
watch every once I watch him every once
he'll talk about certain things I'm like
son of a but but he's he's he can
spend like there's Noor he doesn't have
the X Factor I hope you're right yeah he
does okay I mean he he he may be like
you know he he may be tier one but he's
not special tier right there's people
who are well above sure I would say
Gavin Newsome falls into your standard
ranking of politicians on the high end
okay but Trump Obama I wouldn't
necessarily say George W bush but yes
the people who become presidents have
something above everybody except
Biden Biden was anti- Trump yeah after
he won so new some winning maybe as an
anti- campaign but that's that that's
happen like very rarely in this country
Nome is he's he he may be top tier but
he's not special class Trump trump is
something magical and I don't like I
mean like his Persona his character his
life story his golden toilet there is a
uniqueness to his art Gavin Nome is a
background character Charisma mixed with
intelligence I don't get the
intelligence out of Gavin I don't know
him as well but like Obama had
intelligence and Charisma Trump had
intelligence and Charisma like that's a
big combo Gavin Newsome is Bradley
Cooper Wedding Crashers like Bradley
Cooper went on to become a big famous
actor he's got a prominent role in the
movie but he's not the main character
the biggest it's it's it's Donald Trump
up there in the front with Vince vaugh
and Bradley Cooper is gav Nome and
they're supporting character but one
thing as well that's interesting to
point out though is that you've noticed
that Gavin Newsome r i I might be wrong
on this you can fact check me but he
rarely goes hard or goes after Trump
directly at all now granted there is a
family connection between between the
trumps and and the Newsome family like
not of people aren't aware of you Gil
foil yeah gilfoil yeah who's now like
but you know she she was married to Nome
right right and it's like but he very
rarely like Newsome very rarely goes
after Trump directly you know what I
mean and it's almost like and even like
remember there's a massive uh California
wildfires back in the day when Trump was
in office Trump came out and there sees
the two of them walking together right
and also like hey during when you know
when Gavin had that debate with DeSantis
well I thought Gavin did really well
when you watch Gavin have that uh
interview with hany he like who else
goes on Fox like I'll go on Fox and like
guess what like you know I thought Gavin
Newsome like I hated to admitt it like
oh man he body slammed Hannity I had a
vis did a great job against Hannity is
not much but you know what I mean I had
this this like Vision where I was
hanging out with Nome and ramasami
together like the three of us were
hanging out talking about stuff yeah
that was a good feeling what did you
talk about it it was just as vague as
that nothing like specific but I just
like felt the presence of the two of
them working together that was kind of
an interesting but every once I watch
watch that guy talk and I'm just like I
know he's lying all that but son of a
he's the thing is he he has the
person he has the personality he could
do it I think with him not critiquing
Trump directly it's almost right now at
least because he doesn't want to upset
the DNC and Biden Administration if he
starts attacking Trump directly it makes
it makes it more obvious he sees himself
as the air parent and should be the
Democratic Nom nominee which I think he
has to tiptoe around because when he was
debating um dandis he he went out of his
way to defend Biden right he needs the
Biden support needs their institution
support as much as he needs to Tak his
time I mean he's still relatively young
he's got time he's kind of like waiting
on he's kind of on the bench in case
something happens he's hanging out and
like he's got time he doesn't you know
like for you know for Trump for instance
like this is like Trump's last shot yeah
I want to I want to play this clip and
wokeness just posted here we go I'm
sitting opposite you but you are a
little overweight a little yeah yeah
why if I could figure that out I'd fix
it do you try to die think I can figure
it out Barbara I've had I've had more
diets and lost and gained back more
weight in my lifetime than I care to
count there are people who say that you
couldn't be president because you're so
heavy what do you say to them no it's
ridiculous sta was president but I
completely agree yeah it's a weird come
on man calories calories out don't don't
even don't even and there they're not I
I don't think all food products are the
exact same so I really don't like there
there are people who are like it's just
calories in calories out and I'm like
it's technically true but doesn't help
someone who's like Chris Christie yo
Chris stop eating the bread and the
carbs and the sugar not kidding higher
protein high fat you get some veggies in
there just the dude has clearly not
talked to a nutritionist he has clearly
not even tried and I've seen him in
person up close right one time and I was
like oh my God like the suit like and
and be honest like the a lot of the
suits he wears like these guys you know
it's like those suits are actually
pretty slimming you know if that's if
that's anything but it's it's real bad
and he's actually probably Fair his legs
are probably super ripped because they
have to carry all that weight but yeah
but it's one of those things where it
this sounds crazy but when you see
somebody who's like that big you're like
okay there's something going on there
there's something like deeper than just
like you know it's like well why is this
why is that you know I'm not trying to
like psycho analyze you know he got a
lap band surgery in February 2013 that's
when you get like a belt WRA aroundand
he's still he lost 100 lb that's where
it's like if he's saying and then he
weighed at 320 if he has like some crazy
thyroid issue right like that's the only
way it could be like maybe it's really
difficult for you to lose weight yeah
but that means he's not trying and also
maybe I don't need you to be president
because if you have unexplained medical
conditions like being an alcoholic we
were talking about this the other day
because our our spin drifts are are
certified gluten-free whatever reasons
whatever reason and so you know uh I I I
cut out most carbs and now I've
eliminated bread and from my diet and I
actually feel better than oh 100% dude
like my like even my skateboarding the
clips that I've gotten some of these
tricks you know some of the best I've
ever done sure and uh at 37 I was like
wow I I kind of think the bread is
messing me up I've long thought that I
do I do think cutting out carbs helps
but uh we were talking about it and you
know it usually goes to it's probably
not the bread it's the chemicals they
put in bread in unit States because when
we've had uh European bread imported
flour and things like this or pure
organic yeah it is different it is
different yeah and like look I'm not
suggesting that like hey if you got to
be running for public office you need to
like be the parag on of Fitness or
anything but holy crap you guys like
that's that's yeah that's a lot it's a
health risk and that's a risk to our
national security if the president falls
down and has a heart attack in the
middle of the day on a Tuesday like
what's that going to do to the country
oh dude can't risk that stuff we we've
got you know uh Foo Fighters drummer
right he he died Taylor Hawkins yeah
experiencing chest pains and then dies
yeah and uh some they at first they
claimed he had drugs in the system but
then the band I guess claimed that's not
true he was not doing drugs yeah and and
so I'm like dude if a fit drummer right
and they said he was super exhausted
because they were playing like crazy if
someone that fit yeah is is going to die
of a heart issue or whatever you know
Chris Christie cut out the AO dies Chris
Christie cut him and also say what you
want about you know George W bush that
dude was running like a sub 25k in
office like I mean like that dude like
he like Bush was fit he was athletic
it's I reading a little bit about
Christie he used to be an athlete and
then he quit in his 20s to get into
politics and that was when he was at his
no he was like 350 lbs in in college wa
350 in college
322 322 like football look at this look
at this yeah that's Chris who's that
young Chad so he's that's the thing like
some athletes carry a lot of weight and
like that number sounds weird but he's
like total Chad bro chrisis I want him
to be healthy you know you got it in you
Chris
what there's no excuse intermittent
fasting really it's elimination
what yeah he's eating he's eating
garbage and he doesn't care it's like if
I could figure it out I'd tell you no
that's not even
it I don't eat that much but then they
snack and they don't realize how much is
much you know what's that picture of him
in the baseball uniform earlier there we
go that's a cool one Jersey Boy I see
why they teenager but that like dude's
total chat total stud that's the
politician that I would vote like a guy
like that I'm like he's a leader the
weight issue though is like that's wild
just it's lack of self-control he
started eating and he didn't stop
like like look man you cannot gain
weight if you're not consuming food I'm
not saying starve yourself I'm saying go
talk to a doctor nutritionist there
there are ways they can they can help I
I we we were watching this I watched the
show a long time ago you can probably
Google it and figure out which one it is
and they track people and what they eat
all day and there's these two morbidly
obese women are like we don't eat that
much for breakfast I have a salad and
for lunch I have a sandwich and I keep
gaining weight and so they follow them
around all day filming them at the end
of the day they're like how many
calories do you think you ate and she's
like well for breakfast I had two eggs
and bacon so that's maybe 300 calories
and then I had for lunch a salad so
that's maybe 400 because of the dressing
so I think I'm maybe around 900 and
they're like you're at 37 because you
were eating chocolates and you were
eating chips and every because every few
minutes you'd walk past and grab a
cookie out of a bowl and eat it and
there were like all of the snacks you
ate total thousands of calories yep hey
if we wanted to put a talk about def
flaws on when it comes to candidates one
of things like despite all the
corruption with Nikki Haley and all that
here's the thing and like I know this
might sound like some weird unpopular
and it might sound strange but it's like
okay you were a very popular governor in
at you know in South Carolina you were
the UN Ambassador a lot of people like
you your well-known household name right
even before she started running for
president this time you got a book deal
all this stuff and it's like oh well she
en rich and on the board of Boeing are
you kidding me and it's like she's only
worth in like $8 million like I know it
sounds weird but like for for that level
of game like that's not a lot of
suck there's money somewhere else Buzz
news actually wrote an article 10 years
ago called seven photos of a skinny
Chris Christie oh wow the New Jersey
governor recently had a lap band surgery
to reduce his weight at the urging of
his family well it didn't work wow dude
yeah 10 L it didn't take but uh so we're
gonna we're we're gonna we're going to
wrap things up here I mean this is a
debate night we usually uh we don't do
members only on debate nights because we
don't know how long they go or or um you
kind of General have a general idea but
uh now we're going to wrap it up there
so uh we'll be back tomorrow of course
with the Regular Show and new segments
and all that so you can smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show head over to
timcast.net
it's uh showing people gun culture
explaining the importance of gun rights
and uh you should definitely check it
out and as a member you're helping us do
all of that so we've got more
documentaries being planned we're
launching one one of the biggest private
skateboard facilities in the east coast
because we are building culture yeah
several million dollars H we're
investing several million dollars into a
gigantic private skate facility several
pro skateboarders are coming out we're
going to be wrapping in all the uh
Action Sports and pro elements because
we are going to build and we are going
to take over the culture and push out
the woke elements and we're already
starting to win and that's thanks to all
of your support so again become a member
at
timcast.net uh no was it Boonies HQ on
on Instagram I believe is the is the
handle think so and we're and we're on
YouTube so follow the boonies on YouTube
or search for Boonies HQ I'm not sure
which one it is on YouTube you know
either way you'll find it we just put up
we got a bunch of skate edits that are
going up and the uh the new facility is
currently uh under construction all the
kitchen appliances are coming in you
know free dast stand is coming along
it's going to be super amazing we're
building a massive uh concrete outdoor
section a massive wooden indoor section
and we're going to have mega ramps we're
going to have a lot because uh as the I
was told by these uh large industry Pros
if you build it they will come and so we
intend to and we've already had several
victories against the weird woke
nonsense that I'll get into later
because um we're we're going to play
this one light and not just go for the
throat a lot of the woke people are
trying to destroy our industry but I
really do appreciate everyone's support
we're going to be building a lot of
culture coffee shop of course go to cast
brew.com you can follow the show at
timcast IRL Tom you want to shout
anything out yeah my name is Tom sour
Thomas bour on the Twitter X machine uh
I'm the owner of myar Health we are in
the life-saving business we are here to
save veterans lives from addiction and
mental health uh I've been in DC right
now uh pushing for uh expanded access to
veterans care uh through the VA and
that's what I've come out here I'm out
in DC once a month talking to folks on
the hill and we're really pushing hard
to get the VA to act you know uh
increase the access standards so when a
when a veteran is showing up to their VA
provider in an addiction or Mental
Health crisis that the VA should put
that person into a bed you know in a in
a treatment center within 72 hours which
is not a crazy ask and currently it's
like a month so that's what I'm here
forward I push for uh myar health is the
company Thomas P hour thank you so much
for having me you guys love being here
look forward to coming back for a third
time yeah it's been awesome having you
on it was it was fun night to be on with
wild us and all our friends at the GOP I
guess uh I'm Hannah brimlow I'm a writer
for cnr.com also known as scanner news
shout out to all the team that works
there Chris Carr Chris Bertman and
Cassandra Fairbanks McDon Fairbanks
McDonald's and Adrian Norman and I'm
forgetting if there's anyone else but
guys you're all you're all amazing you
want to follow at timcast news on
Instagram and Twitter still you can see
scanners work there if you want to
follow me personally I'm on Instagram at
hand C.B and I'm on uh Twitter at HC
brimo thank you so much thank you Hannah
CLA uh it is Boonies HQ on YouTube check
it out and subscribe and also Tom your
website with Miramar Health it's Miramar
health.com correct spelled phonetically
as you would think it would y I'm Ian
crossin follow me on the internet
everywhere at Ian Crossland subscribe to
me on YouTube check out my show from
earlier I talked with Chrissy May for an
hour it was awesome and follow my work
there uh every day more or less the show
goes up unless I'm not feeling it or
there's a cancellation or something else
subscribe and I'll see you there and I
am surge.com uh I've been talking to a
lot of you guys on Discord recently I
won't be on there very much but uh I'll
talk to as much as I can
um message me on Twix follow me at
surge.com see you guys uh tomorrow so
with Boon's HQ and with the coffee shop
we're launching our location in
Martinsburg is beginning the process of
launching our second floor private club
hangout and skate shop and so our
initial plan is going to be it's going
to be private uh so if you're a member
of
timcast.net ship for the other website
then you have membership access to come
and hang out in the physical location
and we're going to have skate gear
equipment and other things and it's
going to be at uh lower rates because
you're remember so effectively like a
Costco style but for for a skate shop
and uh you're going to hang out we're
getting right now we're ordering sofas
we're going to we're going to put two
TVs facing away from each other with uh
Playstation Xbox video game consoles so
you can play multiplayer play video
games hangout and uh a lot more planned
for this space it's decently large it's
going to be a lot of fun there's going
to be a little mini bar hangout but it's
private so there's a lot we can do with
a private space and we're hoping to have
that up very very soon because it's
actually really really easy to do all we
got to do is order the stuff and put it
in there and then have someone open the
door and y'all can come hang out going
to be super exciting the coffee shop D
there's a lot of construction that has
to happen so that's taking forever but
the the private club section is going to
be super easy so that's coming really
really soon and uh really excited thanks
for hanging out and we'll see you all
tomorrow